okay uh folks two minutes we're going to
day
well good morning everybody we're going
here I
guess I can do it we gotta get we got to
do a couple things first yeah uh first
we're going to go ahead and uh start the
day uh representative majority you are
up today for the
you
thank you representative Mr clerk could
please Vice chairman power here CER is
here representative Guthrie
representative sales
here representative
Joella representative Kelly
representative aood pres representative
Brown representative kahill here
representative stavis here
representative
Tetro representative CH 11
representative Gilman here represent
Maji
here representative Gallagher
representative Hicks here representative
Howland here
uh representative freeze here
representative frch
pres okay very good uh we are going to
get going I'll have some comments once
on General stuff for the committee later
when everybody's here um first bill up
representative kahill you're a little
early yours isn't until
950 um so we will will start with the
hearing on HB 1052 relative to the
format of Excavating and dredging permit
application the prime sponsor has not
arrived yet but we do have a co-sponsor
who will introduce and speak to the bill
representative
majority
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Jim
majori representing Rockingham 23 the
beautiful town of Northampton um I
preface this by saying I do understand
uh that there is an amendment that is
going to be brought forward I'm not sure
the timing for that but there is a
general support for that Amendment um I
would welcome all questions to be
phrased as would you believe because
there might be some on the committee who
know as much if not more about this bill
than I do anyway uh with that I'd like
to introduce House Bill 1052 relative to
the format of Excavating and dredging
permit applications currently permit
applications need to be submitted in
paper form four of which need to be
submitted to the town with this bill
what we would what we be what we would
be doing is amending RSA 482
A3 uh to allow for one of those to allow
for one paper copy and then a digital
copy uh to be uh submitted to the town
uh again I I know that there's an
amendment coming I might look behind me
and wonder if somebody is going to be
speaking good there is going to be
somebody speaking to this uh with that
very simple summary I would uh open the
floor to any questions that the
committee might have thank you
representative representative power
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question sure
so originally the current
statute requires four copies paper
copies and the bill is changing that as
you stated to one paper copy and a
digital copy so I'd like to understand
um presently why are four copies um
needed and what is done with the four
copies and and my concern is is is One
Cop Cy one hard copy going to be
sufficient for the
purposes thank you for the question and
speaking only from my perspective in
Northampton where we don't get as many
of
these when I brought this up to uh to
the officials in town we only need one
copy it's not being circulated to that
many boards and commissions such that we
need the four hard copies to be
circulated around with one hard that can
be copied and sent to committee and one
digital it sufficed I I I would like to
think that that is what is consistent or
that that same feeling is consistent and
the reason for the bill go ahead thank
you Mr chair so I understand that you're
not the prime sponsor of the bill
correct and that you are the co-sponsor
correct so when I um looked at this bill
in
context um if you put it in context it's
any the previous part of the statute
says any person seeking to obtain a
permit shall submit to the department
and the department in this section of
Statute is referring to the dees the
Department of Environmental Services so
it's that
department that is receiving the four
copies and perhaps I can Reas my
question to someone else oh AB
absolutely and and I would think that
that your question is probably best and
thank you for the question thank you for
the followup I think uh I I would like
to think that the prime uh submitted the
bill for that very same reason and again
maybe I should have been more clear when
speaking about my own Community that's
the way we do it I I can't speak to
exactly that that's the way Dees might
respond to that um but would hope that
the prime might be able to have an
answer to that question I apologize that
I don't thank you for that I did just
receive a text from the prime he's
behind an accident on 93 North nor so
he's still trying to get here and I'm
pretty sure he will have a good answer
for that further
questions seeing none uh representative
lales ye yes thank you Mr chairman and
thank you um I'm just
wondering if there are communities
perhaps in the North
country
that don't deal with electronic copies
as much or if there are any
municipalities that don't have the
capability of dealing with anything
other than paper I I understand that in
most communities the first thing that
the municipality or the department does
is probably turn it into a digital copy
right off the bat but there may be
communities up north
or anywhere really that don't deal with
electronic copies I'm just wondering
about
that thank you for the question and I
and I think that uh I think given some
of the other discussion we've had with
some with some other bills that that
should always be one of the
considerations that we have the capacity
for every Community to be able to
benefit and the even if it's a not the
unintended consequences for those
communities who might not I'm sorry that
I don't have a good answer for you but I
do think that it should be at least a
consideration
thank you Mr thank you for taking my
question is the reason for the four
copies uh the original four copies the
fact that they have to be posted on site
at the dig
sites I thank you for the question I
would have to defer to the Prime on that
for his research into if that is the
sorry
represent power thank you Mr chair I
have a processed question I I understand
that the prime sponsor is not here and
my question is probably better directed
to the prime um could you recommend or
provide guidance as to how this
committee can ask questions of the Prime
absolutely uh at 9:37 the prime said
walking over from the garage now so he
should be here momentarily would you
like me to
[Laughter]
Vamp the 1961 Yankees lineup consistent
no okay we're good any other questions
for representative major seeing none
thank you very much for introducing in
the testimony we have uh one pink card
and I think by the time n is finished uh
here thank you Mr chair H Grace for the
mun
Association um just to give you all a
slight background here um this this bill
came at the request of The molon Boro
town clerk um who worked with a number
of other Town clerks um as the process
currently functions um the municipality
receives four copies of four paper
copies of an
application um and back when this
statute was originally written one copy
would go to the the select board one to
the planning board one of the
Conservation Commission and one was
retained by the town clerk the copy that
went to Dees was apparently scanned and
sent down there um they do that
regularly um given that often times uh
more than one member of the governing
body or the planning board want to
review copies of of this
application it's frequently the case
that town clerks are scanning copies and
so this is really an attempt to help
alleviate the administrative burden at
the local level by ensuring the town
clerk doesn't have to scan the copies
anymore instead they can just have a
fillable PDF or whatever the format is
that um that Dees has for this that
someone fills out
anyway prints out and then hands into
the town clerk who then handles it from
there instead what will happen is they
will send a digital copy that the town
clerk can distribute um as well as a
paper copy uh the amendment that you
will be seen clarifies
that the other local bodies can receive
either paper copies or digital copies at
their discretion because it is clear
that some communities do not have the
capability of Distributing electronic uh
electronic copies and there are of
course some board members who prefer
paper copies so we want to make sure
there was uh discretion there um uh
Additionally the amendment will clarify
a uh make a technical correction as you
may note uh the word digital and
electronic are used interchangeably here
that's that's going away uh I understand
the sponsor is going to pick one of
those so there's no
confusion um
and uh as far far as uh talking with
Dees about whether they were okay with
this process um I did speak with them
they did indicate they were okay with
this change because it would not affect
any affect how Dees processes any of
this paperwork this is just a local
change for what happens to the copies
that are retained at the local level I'm
happy to take any questions the
committee may have representative
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I I'm I'm a
little bit unclear so the D this the the
digital copy and the one paper copy is
going to be
originated and provided by whom to whom
the applicant is going to fill out the
form which is a fillable PDF if I
understand correctly they're going to
send a copy of that digitally to the
town clerk as well as provide a paper
copy um the the town clerk keeps a paper
copy now and wanted to continue to keep
a paper copy because there are
occasionally people who come in to town
hall and want to see the application the
abuts typically because they are noticed
for this because this is a land use
application um so the town clerk can
just hand them the paper copy so they
can review it or if they want a digital
copy they can get a digital copy it
makes it easier for it should make it
EAS easier for
everyone representative
status thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question what's the
problem that this bill purports to
solve So currently the law requires that
a paper copy is four paper copies are
handed in to the town
clerk it is frequently the case that the
town clerks then have to scan those and
email those to Dees as well as the
members of the select board and the
planning board it would be easier for
them if they could simply have a digital
copy in the first place and distribute
appropriate I'm not sure why it was
originally in statute that it has to be
paper or digital but it was so that's
what's what's being addressed represent
Holland so just to
clarify excuse me so the is the town
clerk then submitting the uh digital
copy then to Dees or does the applicant
have to do that
separately if I understood correctly
from what I've been told the town clerk
after sign off submits that to Dees on
behalf of the
applicant represent FR thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
uh I personally have only been involved
in a single um excavation permit and my
question is how does this bill deal with
the the large engineering or surveyor
application
I do not know the answer to that off the
head my only comment on that would I
would be that I don't believe that is
part of the change so I would say
whatever is going on now would probably
remain the same but repres
representative Brown shaking his head
any other questions
represent
Gallagher um so yeah one of my big
issues is open data and things like that
so when it says um other digital format
um I'm wondering um if there are what
requirements on that like what if um
what if uh whoever's having to provide
it decides to put it in just some
unreadable form
format so the the form is generated by
Dees and has to be filled out by the
applicant the reason that uh it's
written provided as a PDF because that's
what's currently used or other digital
format because the Hope was that the
legislature would not have to revisit
this Statute in the future but would
future proof it by allowing Dees to make
changes so if they change to something
other than PDF that they could do so
representative Gallagher go ahead um
so uh in RSA 21 R colon 10 um it's got a
definition of um open data
formats uh would you be open to um
amending uh where it says other digital
format to say um other open data format
as specified by um RSA 21 r10 um
instead or do you think um that uh or do
covered I I assume that Dees would use
whatever guidance already exists in
statute when generating their form I I
don't have an opinion other than that
representative
status like to take a step back for just
a moment and ask a kind of a bigger
picture question
um I haven't done the research so I
don't I'm just I'm asking you uh are
such copies of permits required under
different rsas for different governing
bodies in municipalities and will this
be a if passed would this be something
very different from what's prescribed in
other rsas that require permits to be
submitted I'm just I'm just looking for
a reason why we're being so granular and
specific on this particular permitting
process when there are dozens of other
time for reasons that I do not know the
legislature decided to make this process
very specific in the statute um whereas
others just give discretion to
departments or to um individual
municipalities to to
create um so the attempt here was just
by the town clerks to help them
internally do their process a little bit
more
efficiently see no more questions thank
you very much for your testimony I have
no more pin cards uh we will go ahead
hb152
okay next up we have and right on time
kahill thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee uh we're going to open up
the the hearing on House Bill 1218
relative to voting for municipal bonds
representative kahill you have the floor
thank you Mr chair uh please forgive my
eagerness it's just uh Municipal and
county has a soft spot for me it's where
I passed my very first bill and a couple
afterwards so let's keep that
going
um many of us I I would think the
majority of us in this room were elected
by less than 60%
margins and yet we vote on bills that
you know add or cut costs we vote on the
budget and I think that requiring a 60%
threshold for the municipal bonds is is
very high I understand it was
166% let's not go there but it does
impede progress that we need to make an
Our
communities um and I have a few examples
of uh situations where you know we
should have as you know as my aunt
Regina used to say we should have you
know
so as I as as I told you my most of my
interest in this has been with the
public schools that we we have a lot of
public schools in very poor condition uh
those of you you know you all represent
district with schools and either they're
recently renovated or they will will
need to be renovated it's if if not now
with when you know
but uh just prior to the moratorium a
$23 million renovation major renovation
for Stevens High School up in
Claremont uh a school that was built in
1867 they got their mone's worth uh they
that they had a bond vote and it was one
vote shy of
60% and I I know you can always be one
vote shy you know but that was close and
uh so they didn't that
failed and with that they were a 60%
community so they would have
received
um they would have received a
substantial sum to pay for that but
instead a couple of years later into the
moratorium they did a they downsized it
so they could you know get more people
on board it was far less than that what
the community needed and they passed it
uh for 12.6 million you know nearly half
and they cost him $3.4 million
you know really
in that that's what they that's what
they they
spent because they they they missed out
on the on the state aid and they had far
less school for the money uh the Lincoln
acrian School in Hampton Falls six tries
to to renovate their uh their
school
and you know they cut it from 7 to 4
million and they got less and less for
theiry
when they did that alurn and Hudson
there were actually a CTE School in W
there was a schedule uh every so often
it's it's your turn to get money and a
lot of it's Federal money uh so the
voters supported that that part of the
project and but failed to approve the
renovation of the high school and it
probably would have made a lot of
Economic and physical you know sense to
do them all at once I know that's what
was done in in Salem uh they had a major
High School renovation they got uh the
they had the CTE rolled into it as did
do it makes a big difference you don't
have to bust people to some other place
for those Career Technical education and
you had the federal money so we can't
all have CTE schools you know that we
don't but they do serve an important
role
um so I have here you know as you know
we we had 17 applications for building
Aid it reopened and now we're funding
some of them and we funded three so the
other
14 on this list
here and I think some of these some of
these Community names will be familiar
to you uh Amherst has two projects
Barnstead haris Brookline has two
colbrook has two conquer Derry has two
Hamstead has a project har Brook line
there's more uh Hudson kage Litchfield
Monroe Plymouth and there's uh just
under 8,000 students enrolled in those
schools and they were kind of waiting
for their communities to be able to pass
a warrant
article uh so that they will have a
better quality education uh young
families will want to move there raise
their children work and live in the
communities maybe maybe own a start a
business I know that in New Market the
you know the word was um the elementary
school's okay but once your kid goes you
want to leave town before you before
they got to the sixth grade in the other
building which you know was built in in
uh
1925 and had a few additions to it so
you know we we need to make the
Investments I know you know it's like U
it's like pulling teeth you know getting
we we did something a few years ago to
protect the loons we took out the the
lead tackle but we still haven't got the
fish hooks out of our pockets and I I I
think that a simple majority like the
way that we're elected might be a way to
enable the communities to pass these
Warren articles a little sooner uh
probably a little cheaper than than
dragging out and waiting and waiting for
construction cost to rise so that is why
I brought this bill to you
today thank you are you open to
questions represent are there any
questions
representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question I
understand the importance of what you're
talking about um exitor had a 16 point
something million police station that we
were looking for and it failed by six
votes and we don't have a charter so
it's a three- fifths
requirement um putting it up again now
the price is higher as you explained but
but the question that came to me is are
we not
um
uh I can't think of the word
um ex or or denying the voters an
opportunity to say
no uh thank you for the question I I
think what we would do if we had a
simple majority we'd be encouraging
voters on both sides of the issue to
learn more about the project participate
and to show up and vote we wouldn't be
saying well H they'll never pass this I
home representative
Guthrie thank you Mr chairman thank you
for your put your article because I know
this is a big
problem uh I I come from Hamstead we do
believe that we had a fire station
Edition and a police station that we
didn't get I think it was two times on
each one we ended up putting it in the
budget and can can you maybe uh discuss
what happens when you have this kind of
a uh a budget uh item that's of that
that much value and what that does to
the tax rate and what are the
ramification for go going into the
budget where you don't have to have the
two-thirds uh uh thank you uh
representative I'm afraid I don't have
the the background to you know about the
implications what it does to this to the
bond rating I don't think it would be
good but I'm just guessing because I I'm
not I'm not on the any of the budget
committee or The Count Council um so I
don't know how that what the negative is
but I do know what it's like when you
have these projects that need to be done
even people may agree they need to be
done but you're trying to find some way
to kick it down the road uh and the road
needs to get paved
too right if I may Mr CH follow up I
don't think I was clear I was trying to
get a reaction to you of when there is
an item that is normally bonded you go
before the the towns and you get
rejected because of the uh the two3
that's required what do you take take
that budget and you put it in I mean you
take that item you put it in your
budget you want I'm I'm trying to make a
point that that has a
real strong impact on the uh tax rate
representative Guth do you have a is
there a question in there somewhere I
would believe I would I haven't heard it
yet I would believe
yeah uh again representative uh I I uh I
understand that you know it's probably a
bit of desperation that brings the
community to do that and somehow or
other the taxpayer will pay for it um
and you you can try but sooner or later
you have to get these things done and I
just like to move it a little faster
hopefully a little cheaper and have
people buy into the process you know at
the
beginning gra out of power thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
do you agree that a municipal bond is a
very serious Financial commitment it's
multi-year large amounts over the the
term of of the bond and it commits the
taxpayers to subsequent multi-year you
know Financial commitment
so could you please explain to me and
and therefore that's why we have a super
majority because it's it's it's
different than it's a a different level
of spending with different um criteria
or not criteria but
terms so could you explain more clearly
um why then is a simple majority
sufficient for such a serious financial
obligation uh on the backs of the
taxpayers uh thank you representative
for the question I agree it is
serious and I think the the delay that
we that we fre quently see leads to
Serious uh overages and expenses and an
impact on our communities where we have
people looking at for a place to start a
business or raise a family and they're
saying no I think I'm going to go here
instead I really think it's in our
long-term interest to to think of the
long-term health of our communities and
make these Investments and I again I
would hope that we we would still have
substantial margins but falling shy of
60% in so many instances I I think it
it representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman thanks for the uh for being
here and taking this question did you
say your primary motivation is for um
communities to receive state and federal
funding to make it easier for that is
that what I'm hearing from you to lower
the threshold to a simple
majority thank you for the question I
mean certainly we're we're possible you
know communities do pursue grants and
and and funding from various
sources and sometimes I I know with the
situation with with building Aid that we
have now for schools uh the voters don't
know if they're going to get building
Aid or not well we knew during the
moratorium didn't we but we but we don't
know now whether we'll be getting that
and I that's another issue we've been
working on but um certainly uh reducing
costs getting the getting the best bang
for your buck that that's the duty that
the members of the school board Town
Council budget committee and our
municipalities have and and I know that
they they're delegated to review these
these projects and very often they come
through it with a unanimous vote and
still the community falls short of
60% representative kahill for
representative
kahill thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question would you believe
that if
had passed a bond a few years ago to
pave our destroyed roads it would have
been cheaper for us to have done it then
than it would be now representative
kahill I do believe that thank you for
taking my
question representative
T thank you Mr
chair
um hypothetically you're looking
to
I'm trying to narrow this down
um to
circumvent the super Bond requirement or
super vote on a
bond um which is in
law um how would that so if you expand
that um we have a bill come up on the
floor that uh
didn't get the super majority at at chcr
or something like
that I'm hearing that oh we didn't get
it but we still want it so we'll just
vote it in the regular budget into the
sense thank you I didn't hear a question
there either representative kahill
so representative y Ella thank you thank
you for taking the question um do you
think that it is prudent for the
taxpayers um money to
utilize um the saving account options
that uh as far as um Expendable trusts
and all of that um which Acure AC aure
interest instead of paying additional
money um uh and saving for those
expenditures like the roads and and
school things instead of um on the back
end paying more because of interest uh
through bonds and so the the um state is
inent essentially incentivizing savings
instead of um loans uh through this
simple majority
option thank you representative for the
question uh
the communities of municipalities do put
aside money with voter approval for you
know 200,000 here for this and that they
do set it aside for maintenance and and
and things as part of their it's another
article on on the budget many times uh
and they certainly do use those funds to
reduce the amount that we need to
bond and uh I I think this is a separate
issue where we're not we're
uh we're asking the communities we're
giving the communities the option to
bond Less in the long run because if we
don't drag our feet and wait until who
knows what happens we we do it when we
need it rather than saving for we I
think it's impractical to say we're
going to save up uh in my case $39
million before we build the school we'll
have generations of
people you know will have gone wouldn't
unfortunately we can't write off the
mortgage interest thank you
representative seeing no further
questions thank you for your testimony I
have no other pink cards uh I have a
blue sheet with nobody signed in for it
for or against so with that we will
close the hearing on hb1 1218 we're in a
rare situation we're actually ahead of
our time so I'm going to use yeah I know
um had a schedule I should say uh going
to use this time since most of us just F
everybody's here couple qu couple points
um you might have you did receive a
email from me regarding the possibility
of executing three bills on Thursday I
would um that those may or may not go so
be pay very careful attention on the
house floor on Thursday because that's
where that announcement would have to
come from to make everything
legal um now we talked about this at at
the beginning of last
week when you hey Richard um
representative Brown I'm sorry could you
somebody when we hear testimony from
those giving the testimony we need to
only the only thing we're supposed to be
doing is asking questions questions
regarding their testimony not going off
into the Weeds on different uh
things even slightly related but we we
need to keep it focused on what they say
the other thing we talked about last
week is the W you believes are not
something here when we get to Executive
sessions that's where we Talk Amongst
ourselves in committee about what we
believe and make our points there not
here uh
lastly when you have a
question try to have
it succinct and to the point be ready to
When I Call On you to have that question
so when we ask it it's quick and we can
there questions on any of
that seeing none our next uh hearing
starts at
minutes
minute oh she's making a way to her seat
okay
Gavin okay it's 10:20 we're going to go
ahead and open up the next uh hearing on
HB 11:25 relative to requiring public
notice and comment at all County
Commissioner and delegation meetings
representative buroughs Prime sponsor
mic thank you Mr chair thank you for
having me here I'm Anita burrow Carol to
I'm one of the um sponsors of this bill
um this is a pretty simple it's a
bipartisan Bill and it basically uh is
is uh promoting that there be
requirement for public notice and
comment at all County Commissioner and
delegation meetings so the current law
states that public comment in a county
commissioner delegation meeting is a
privilege but not a right and I believe
that it should be both a that it should
be both a privilege and a
right um and this bill was filed after a
scenario that I witness um in Carol
County and I just want to tell you this
short story um a citizen was concerned
about the Financial Health of um our
nursing home there was a lot of
controversy there was a lot of articles
in the paper so he call he's a
healthcare consultant and he understood
how to analyze financial statements he
did this for a living so um he went on
the zoom to express his concern and ask
a question and he was recognized to
speak he then proceeded to express his
concern about the health of the nursing
home financially the commissioner tried
to give reassurance that um that the
nursing home was was doing well she said
the nursing home was just fine and he
very respectfully said Madam Madam chair
chairman I respectfully degree uh
disagree because I read financial
statements for a living and the at this
juncture the commissioner repeatedly
gaveled uh for this consultant to stop
talking as he did and I'm going to say
at this juncture for um transparency
this gentleman was my husband um but I
would have I would have I would have uh
put forth this whether it was him or
somebody else and and at the next
meeting another commissioner chastised
this man mentioned that he was my
husband for his rude behavior and no
time was he rude um and he again
reiterated that public comment is a
privilege and not a right now what are
the key highlights of the bill public
comment is either written comment
addressed to the commission or
delegation and delivered prior to a
meeting each person shall be granted at
least three minutes to speak in person
and remote spoken comment is allowed and
there should be a sign in process for
people wishing to speak um so that we
know that that they're there and that
they they have signed up and they they
want to be recognized
um and that the commissioner delegation
does have the right to set up a
procedure for recognizing people who are
on remotely and every person with a card
or on the zoom should be allowed to
speak and all meetings shall be open to
the public whether in person telephone
or by computer
if the charter of any city or town or
guidelines or rules of any public body
require a broader access to broader
public access to official meetings and
Records such guidelines or Rules of
Order take presidents over this
legislation again as I said before this
bill is straightforward and bipartisan
by enabling public comment citizens can
bring a spotlight on any issue and show
elected officials that their pass may
not be the best one for their
constituents in a democracy the
government should serve the people and
not vice versa it is CR critically
important that citizens participate so
that the government and our elected PE
our elected officials are serving the
people therefore it's essential that we
create the expectation that people are
allowed to speak even if there is a
disagreement with our elected officials
thank you and happy to take any
questions thank you representative for
the testimony Representatives uh power
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question and providing your um
testimony so at the beginning of your
testimony I heard you say that the the
gentleman in your example that you cited
had um I guess approached well he was on
Zoom he was on Zoom so you started off
and you you mentioned that he had asked
a question and then he proceeded to
provide I mischaracterized that he did
not ask a question because you can't ask
a question in those meetings so I
mischaracterized it he made a statement
he made a statement and at which which
point he was gaved okay so thank you but
I I'll continue on okay I'm sorry didn't
mean to interrupt you thank you for
clarifying that because that's where I'm
going so just then to to be
clear it's my understanding that this
bill as written you don't intend for the
the public providing input or comment to
be asking questions because clearly
public comment or input is not a back
and forth It's not a place or the time
for the public to be asking questions
and expecting answers it it is just to
provide commentary is that correct dis
agreed and I misspoke um I misspoke I
was speaking too
you represent
yel thank you thank you for taking the
meetings uh would not would all benefit
from the same level of openness to the
public and having public comments
so why if any should should
uh County Commissioners or or the that
delegation um be specified out or should
it be for everyone um I'm going to be
really Frank I was advised that this it
would be be it would have better chance
of Passage doing this way and I think
there also if we included local meetings
I think that there would have been push
back about local control and I think
that was the you know that was the
this F the questions representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um it's interesting uh I have a couple
matters but I'll just do one Mr chair um
the posting of the meeting I understand
that it needs to be on the website and
currently it's uh they're sent out to
all the delegates when there's a a
delegation meeting um but if in the
entrance of
transparency wouldn't it
be uh better to require be posted in all
towns because like for example in my
County um the county building is really
not accessible even in the town it's in
and so I was I my thought is would it be
you know within this transparency and
posting to require to be posted in two
places in each Town I'd be totally
supportive that that because we do we I
get a lot of calls from people you know
how do I find out when the meeting's
happening I really want to be there
when's this issue going to be spoken
about so I I would be totally supportive
of
that further
questions
sorry represent Gilman that's okay it's
not really a follow-up so I want to do a
second question the other is um a person
that wants to ask uh talk in public
comment you ask uh that they're required
to give their name and as printed on the
driver's license or ID for
identification but they're not required
to provide any further personal
information um at my select board
meetings we ask a person that's from
without our from uh without our town
from you know surrounding town or city
um to identify that and then by
consensus the board agrees to let this
person be heard um you know hardly ever
say no but I'm wondering if we need to
also add the the words in there that um
about there be consensus to allow
somebody from outside the county oh
county I I think that would be
reasonable but not not for somebody who
lives in the county and in terms of
identification frankly Carol County is
pretty small most people know each other
you know we know you know it's very rare
that somebody comes in that somebody
doesn't know that person but I think it
would be reasonable I mean we do get New
Hampshire some hearings there are more
people from out of state than in state
wanting to test testify and that can be
problematic
y further questions representative Brown
thank thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative burough I have a kind of
a question to you in regard to
representative Gilmore's question to you
and regard to um notification if you
were to revise the bill to say something
along the lines that it would be
required to be posted in the towns of
the county that whether or not that
would be uh problematic in regard to the
to the posting time so you could post it
in let's say the county and then if the
towns don't get it all posted in an
appropriate time period then that could
be an issue for that do you feel that
could be a problem or how do you feel
about
that again I I actually don't know
offand what the what the time period
requirement is for both commission and
delegation meanings what the period of
time is so you know maybe the language
would be something to the effect of to
their best ability you know it could be
you know it could be like for example
the Conway Daily Sun has an event column
they could post it there so I mean I
think there are a lot of ways to go
there are you know towns have um online
forms I I think there are ways to do it
and do it quickly but you know I I I
think that's something that needs to be
looked at thank you
y representative
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking another question so with
regards to um the public comment and in
here in the bill under Section Roman
numeral 4 that there's the person will
fill out a card they won't just stating
their name my question is how will what
is the how can their residency within
the county be be validated or determined
if they're only giving their name when
you had established that in order to
give the public comment the person must
be a resident of the
county I appreciate the question I'm
just thinking ahead and I'm thinking of
another scenario where would have
somebody from another County let's say
that there's an issue going on in Carol
County that um that that I'm just going
to that a town in um Rochester had this
similar situation which actually is true
they had some similar issues with n
Nursing Home in that scenario I would
think that it would be not a bad idea to
let that person speak if there was
relevancy to their
experience follow up thank you
representative for for that response
like what I'm getting at is would it
make sense to have an amendment where
the person would provide identification
supplying their name and like the town
so that way the people running in the
meeting can can know is this person
within the county where they can provide
the input without any extra consensus
and if they're outside of the county
then that that is known and then they
can people running the meeting can go
from there you see what I'm saying yes I
do see what you're saying I my response
to that to be I would like to see that
something that the county decides how to
handle that again because our County as
I said is small it's very different than
some of the places in Nash Manchester
where you don't know who's walking in
the door so you know I was coming in
with that framework so I think it might
county is your hand up representative
Elward Elward
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um do you think as a
matter of pract
practicality that rather than trying to
legislate Town involvement on these
postings that the county commissioner
just encouraged the town to post a link
to the County
website
um I just again in my experience I just
see too many people who want to have a
say in County government they don't even
know that there's a County website and
so maybe there's also an education facet
to it but I do think you know making a
posting in the local paper or something
like that there's a section you don't
even have to pay for it it's events um I
I think that would be really helpful
thank
you further
questions see and I do have a couple
representative um the first one I just
want to clarify
is it your intention for this bill that
only individuals from the county be
allowed to speak under this section no
as I as I just said I think there are
scenarios where it's appropriate and I
think there are scenarios when it's not
appropriate okay thank you um on line
number
10 um you have the words penalty
retribution or disrespect could you
define for me let's just pick one of
them let's pick disrespect respect and
Define what that is well I think the
example I just gave you with my husband
showed contempt and disrespect um for
somebody who was just trying to make a
comment and uh follow up for the
chairman who who's going to make that
who's going to decide whether it's
disrespect retribution or penalty that
is a very good question that is a very
good question and my final comment on
that line or question would be and after
it's decided who will make that
decision uh what is the remedy for
that well I guess in in in let's just
let's just say the example that I gave
this person being gaveled I think the
remedy for that would be to allow them
to come back and speak and finish what
they were
saying okay thank you very much
representa
sis thank you Mr chair and thank thank
you representative for taking my
question uh in um section two of the
bill on line nine it says any
person shall be permitted but then it
goes down and limits that to someone
with a valid ID I would you be amendable
to amending that since it says any
person should be any person okay what
line are you on please first of all I'm
online nine okay which states any person
shall be permitted goes on and then uh
it's lines 22 through through uh 23 I
believe person shall be required to give
their name as printed on their driver's
license I I'm just thinking that those
two things cancel each other out by
saying any person if it's any person
it's any person and if it's a public
meeting for example and and I apologize
Mr chair this may not sound like a
question but it is a
question in our city council meetings in
Lebanon where we have Wards and we have
public comment periods we ask people to
State their name and what Ward they live
in but there's no requirement that they
show any
identification so I'm asking would you
be amendable to absolutely the section
requires that AB I I think they you know
it's every county is so different it's
just so different but yes I'd be amable
that further comments or question or
questions no comments seeing none thank
you very much for your testimony thank
you very much I have the blue sheet
again nobody signed in in for or
against and I have no more pin cards so
hb125 boy the chairman has gone the off
done the opposite
today we're too far ahead all right well
going
okay folks we're going to get going
again
here okay we're going to go ahead and
open up the public hearing on HB 1242
relative to establishment of a
countywide Communications District
and representative Howard welcome to
Municipal and County you're up thank you
Mr chair and thank you fellow
representatives for having me today uh I
know that we hear this a lot but HB 1242
is fairly straightforward in its
language uh in that it enables counties
to establish Communications districts
for those of you who are unaware of what
Communications districts are under RSA
53- G they operate as a service provider
by creating Partnerships with a
corporate body for the primary purpose
of establishing a communication District
uh or a Broadband Network my bad uh this
will not change the operations of
current Communications districts and
will only make the process of
establishing a district easier these
Partnerships are great but not many
municipalities are taking advantage of
this wonderful system because its
economies of scale are geared more
towards a county level operation like
what they have done with the Carroll
County communications District the need
for each town to pass a warrant article
makes establishment unnecessarily
lengthy and a complex process that HB
fixes uh while still giving
municipalities the final say with the
included opt out in the bill I hope that
you'll join me in supporting this
enabling legislation to give counties
the choice as well as towns uh how they
want to approach Broadband in the future
thank
you thank you for your testimony stand
repr representative yella thank you
thank you for taking the question um in
your testimony you mentioned Carol
County has a communication District
um so this bill is allowing counties to
have a communication District so I guess
my question is um if a communication
district for a County already exists
then why is this legislation necessary
that's a very good question so under the
current um rsas we have uh establishment
through individual towns passing the
warrant article so each Town needs to uh
band together and basically on an
individual basis go and establish this
uh this would change that by instead of
trying to make this a proactive process
amongst every town if a County or a
group of towns want to create a
Communications District rather than
having uh to go through each of the
towns it would be easier to just allow
the county to create a referendum and it
still allows for the opt out so if towns
do not want to participate uh like the
town of wolfboro is not a part of the
communications District up in Caroll
participate representative
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I'm a little
confused because um as you stated
typically um
districts are formed for a specific
purpose in that the towns or
municipalities interested come together
to form that that district and as you
stated in your testimony Carol County
has a Communications District district
which was formed by that procedure town
coming together creating the
communications
District this bill as written is it true
that it's to do the inverse process
where the district would be
Communications countywide communication
District would be established and then
towns would join and and I don't
understand I don't see there's still a
process by which the towns need to
join or say I don't want to join so I
don't really see how this bill is
solving anything so under the
rsas um uh
for
establishment you have to go through a
planning committee and basically this
would allow the county to establish a
planning committee so that they can move
forward with the process because the
corporate body is separate from the
county they're not they're not linked
necessarily it just allows the inverse
to happen because it's a lot easier for
the towns to propose a referendum uh
like this is a fairly big issue uh up in
the north country and so for a number of
towns up there they may want to say to
their County government we would like to
propose a referendum to the other towns
rather than having to go to each select
board and convince them to be a part of
this so it would instead propose uh that
as
uh rather to trying to get people to
join together there's only a handful of
districts in the entire State because
they're incredibly difficult to set up
Carol County is kind of the exception uh
they they've done a really good job up
there and I think that it would be great
formed representative majori thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
my question I wonder then if I
understand this correctly if there
should be language included in the
RSA that that um that gives the the
county the warrant article are you are
you suggesting that the warrant article
has to then go to each community on
behalf of the county to State what it
wants to do and and the and the limits
to that maybe I misunderstood so uh
basically uh under the way that the uh
languages written uh let me hold up one
second um it would allow governing
bodies uh of municipalities to uh kind
of reject whatever is proposed but um it
may need a little bit of tweaking in
some of the language and I'd be
definitely willing to work with you on
that represent stavis thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
have County Commissioners come to you
and requested this uh so actually the uh
Association of counties has unanimously
voted to support this bill uh and it it
it is something that I've discussed with
Commissioners representative
priest thank you Mr chairman for taking
my question and thank you for being here
um wouldn't there be an economic uh
scale
um effect
Effectiveness with this bill that would
save money for all the towns within the
district as well as time yes uh exactly
that's that's kind of the primary reason
bill further
questions seeing none thank you for your
you
uh next we have Kate
sec representative Howard before you
leave could you please fill out a pink
card for us thank you all right
represent uh Kate Hogan thank you Mr
chairman I don't need the promotion
today but thank you very much U my name
is Kate Horan I am here on behalf of the
New Hampshire Association of counties
which is all your elected and appointed
officials at County government level um
I in my haste this morning in the office
I forgot my hard copies but all in your
inboxes are a copy of the association's
letter um so you do have that and I will
drop hard copies off with the committee
assistant later today just so you can
have them um this uh as representative
Howard said the association is in
support of this bill we see it as a way
for communication districts uh to be set
set up uh more efficiently and at less
cost um it is an an optin option so if a
town decides that they don't want to or
I'm sorry it's an opt out option so if
towns don't want to participate they
don't have to um but it we do see it as
a benefit for some of our more Northern
counties that are still on dialup
service to expand their Broadband uh
capacities and planning as they move
through it could also serve as a
Communication Center for both
constituents and the internet service
provider that is involved with the
communications District um with that I
will close my testimony I am not a
Communications District expert but I
will do my best to answer any questions
that you
have okay thank you any questions
representative
yella thank you thank you for the uh
opportunity to take uh ask this question
um it says on line 12 and 13 that the
governing body
um is able to exclude themselves and
it's um I assume that means that that
it's not going to the voters to decide
whether or not they want to be part of
this um District or not
um how what is
the logic of not going to the voters
instead of so I did I did not write this
language so that would probably be a
more appropriate question for
representative Howard but it will it
depends upon how the town is set up
right and what form of government are
they an sb2 town are they a town meeting
town because I know the ways that they
uh opt in and opt out of things are
handled differently in those different
towns but I would I would direct you to
representative Howard to okay thank you
but if you wanted to change that
language to send it to the voters I
that further questions repres uh
representative
Solace thank you Mr chairman and thanks
for taking my
question if there's a financial
advantage of a county doing this rather
than the individual
towns why wouldn't we go all the way and
have a Statewide Communications
District thank you for the question
representative lales um I think that's
something you should discuss as a
committee but I would also point out
that I tell you all very frequently that
there are 10 counties and each County
does things 10 different ways um and
there are different needs at Coos than
there are in Hillsboro and Rockingham
just based on their infrastructure so I
think the countywide model is a good
model because it allows counties who are
already working together with their
towns and communities to address their
county follow uh go ahead is there
anything that would
prohibit various counties perhaps
Hillsboro and Rockingham or Hillsboro
Rockingham and marac could go together
is there anything to prohibit that from
happening the way I read this language
you further questions represent
St
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking this question if I can get rid of
the frog in my throat
um the question that representative
lalis just asked about malti County in
line nine of the bill it says one
County so in order to give an
affirmative answer to representative
lellis would that have to be changed um
I think because the way that I read it
and if this needs to be edited I'm not a
lawyer it could certainly be done but
the way I read it is it's two or more
towns or one
County but you could add on other
counties one County would just be the
other counties could participate in that
Communications District but there would
County for the
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you very
much okay that's all the pink card I
have um another blue signin sheet with
nobody on it for Pro or con so with that
we will go ahead and close the hearing
on HB
12:42 and once again we are ahead of
11:30
[Music]
properly
a
A.M
one
minutes
representative sellers have you filled
yet
okay we're going to go ahead and open up
the uh hearing on HB
1302 relative to elected conservation
commissions uh in towns Prime sponsor
representative
up uh good morning committee uh thank
you Mr chair for this opportunity uh I
am representative sellers I'm from
Grafton district 18 I represent 10 towns
in southern Grafton
County um
and you're just do okay so let me just
uh I have some notes that I actually
handed out to you folks there that a uh
constituent actually provided to me
which was very helpful and also I'm
somewhat aware of this uh issue and
being in a small town we have about
3,000 residents about 2,000 voters and
this is basically is to establish um the
opportunity so if the town wants to
actually if its residents of the Town
its voters of the town want to actually
create a conservation committee by
election that's the opportunity right
now they're they're signed and that's
all they can be they can be appointed or
assigned by the select board they don't
have the opportunity of
voting and therefore you know if you
don't have that opportunity in some
cases and again it's totally up to the
town the town doesn't have
to uh you know they could decide that no
we don't want an elected uh conservation
committee and which is fine but Town
might say yeah you know what it's a good
idea let's you know we'll bring it to
the voters the voters vote Yes okay from
then on out it's now elected so that's
what this is all about it's pretty
straightforward that way and and in the
handout I gave I gave to you here this
there's some good reasons you know to
have it you know and a couple reasons uh
with not having it as well and I'm not
going to read through them all you have
them in front of you at this point but
you know overall that's a couple things
that stand out it um bullet point two uh
distributes centralized control of who
serves on the conservation committee you
know from the select select board or
select men to the voters you know again
giving the control back to the voters
which is to me that's uh that's that's
expanding what we have today instead of
just being all right we select board we
we voted for you and now besides running
the whole town we also want you to run
the conservation committee too well this
allows the voters to say would like to
run it as
well all right it it would stop you know
in a case of uh a resident who is Maybe
not well-liked maybe is good for the
committee but the select board or select
people don't like them or her you know
so this would actually stop that you
know if that's the case I mean we live
in small towns we know this happens you
know it does happen
um the transition doesn't take you know
it doesn't take effect like you know
that first year it can actually uh it
can be over three years so it's not uh
all in the same
year um this is no different or or very
similar to the planning board or zoning
board which is elected in the towns all
right so think of it that way you know
we elect our zoning of planning
boards other than that I'm available to
take questions and uh we'll go from
there because I'm sure there will will
be some and I'll do my best to answer
what I can representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question on uh
line 15 and
16 the selectman May remove an elected
member for caruse after public
hearing what what are your thoughts on
that what what is
cause so the again this is set up the
same exact way as the planning of Zone
board would be so instead of having a
different language altogether why not
just have the same you know it's because
now if you're going in with different um
languages you know hey the planning
board does it this way and we have to do
it this way for the conservation
committee and we have to do it this way
for the zoning board it would get very
confusing and and also take up more time
on the uh select board so thank
you rep uh representative
Gallagher uh hi I was wondering um if
you could tell us a bit more about the
motivating case for this legislation
like what
exactly would the um what exactly might
the harm be for having a Conservation
Commission chosen by the current method
that might lead a municipality to want
to elect them instead
so you're asking what what the harm
would be by creating a
voted well by not by by not electing
them by continuing to do things the
current
way well at this point here on one of
the bullet points is uh let's say I've
been in town for 10 years and um maybe
I'm very outspoken at town meeting and
and they don't like what I say and yet I
want to be on the conservation committee
because I love the conservation and I
can't get on it because the select Bo
don't they don't like me you know so
it's and it's like it's too bad maybe I
maybe I have a degree in it as well and
it's like I can't be used and therefore
that's the harm of not having it you
know so you keep it as it is you might
have a good qualified person that would
like to be on it that just can't get on
what representative Elward thank you Mr
chairman and welcome representative
sellers on line 15 and 16 it was
mentioned that the selectman May remove
an elected member for cause after a
public hearing and we know in the land
use statutes that that is as well for a
planning elected planning board member
but does not the statute um land use
statute specify negligence Mal feasance
and
inefficiency um as the cause for
removal can I answer
that Mr chairman um I'm sitting here as
a co-sponsor the prime sponsor had asked
that I that I'd be here to help answer
questions could I respond to that or no
yes you may so thank you for the
question representative um this this to
be clear this bill is enabling it's
enabling legislation therefore was
signed into law it would be enabling
statute um to answer your question here
this um Bill to allow the Conservation
Commission to be elected as opposed to
appointed appointed the language was
taken from um the language um elsewhere
in statute for the enabling legislation
to elect the planning board and so I I
do understand it sounds like you're
saying that in that other area of
Statute that instead of having
um this selectman may remove an elected
member for
cause I think I hear you saying that
that is expounded upon and is listed out
negligence malfeasance and inefficiency
so therefore um the sponsors of this
bill would be open to an amendment to
provide that um parallelism and clarity
thank
you representative
Guth thank you Mr chairman thank you for
your testimony I should say at the
beginning I'm a
selectman do you know first of all do
you know of any other situation where a
person who wanted to be on the
denied uh sir I do not all right
personally thank you all that's fair uh
follow up Mr chairman follow up go ahead
yeah do you know what the
responsibilities are of a Conservation
Commission
member again sir I've never served on
the conservation committee I brought
this bill up uh for as a constituent
would like so I've never served that
area I I I I know they deal with
conservation that's it thank you Mr
chairman by the way I would run for
selectman in your town if I were
you
representative
kill thank you Mr chair thank you uh for
taking my question um in in Raymond we
experience some of
the that that's the word um some of what
you described where a person wasn't
allowed to be on a board because they
weren't liked by the selectman do you
think that maybe this legislation should
include other boards like zoning boards
and things like
that do you say think the same thing
happens with with them well well they're
they're right now they're elected
according to
statute that's already in law they
zoning and and zoning and planing boards
are elected according if the town wants
them at that point I don't know if if I
would think if someone is not liked in
town they probably wouldn't be liked on
any of the
boards that's my point all right and and
honestly I mean I speak out a lot at
town meeting and say you know for could
be budget it could be uh any uh other
warrant article that they bring up you
know and it could be easily enough
myself to say well we don't want him on
this board because he's too outspoken so
I would be concerned that this does not
just happen in conservation it could be
committee are there any further
questions representative
stavis so if if you are concerned that
it could happen on any other commission
or Committee in a town why doesn't this
bodies uh right now the bill actually
focuses on the conservation committee
that's it and again it's only to allow
the people to vote if they would like to
have an elected conservation
committee if statue allows other
committees to be the same way uh that
would have to be brought up at a
different time that's not on what I
proposed follow up thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking this follow-up
question so the intent of this
bill that proposes to change change a
significant piece of process for
municipalities enabling or not for those
towns that choose to do it be a major
change is to ensure that a person who is
maybe not
liked might be
elected am I am I clear on
that well just because you're not liked
by the select board doesn't mean you're
not liked by the town's people so they
could be elected because again I as I
stated I could have all the credentials
in the world that I'm an excellent
conservationist but if you're not liked
appointed are there any further
sellers seeing none thanks for your
testimony and now we will call since I
have a pink card representative power I
think in the future it' be best to do
one at a time representative power we'll
floor thank you Mr chairman um I
apologize for um Coming to the witness
stand with the prime sponsor he asked
that that that I sit um with him to be
able to answer questions in the future
um I will not do that so um again thank
you Mr chairman and honorable committee
members as a co-sponsor I appreciate the
opportunity to provide my testimony with
regards to House Bill 1302 for the
record I am representative Diane hour I
represent the towns of Brookline Mason
and Greenville in Hillsboro County
District
36 today I would like to offer you an
example of the inadequacies of the
current method of appointing members to
the Conservation Commission that
occurred in my house
district in an effort to illustrate to
you why this bill is needed and why you
should consider it
carefully so a few years ago there was
an opening on a particular Town conser
Conservation Commission it was
advertised the opening because a current
member who had been appointed by the
select board was moving out of town a
relatively well-known um resident wanted
to serve on the Conservation Commission
they had a a degree science in in a
scientific degree they um had background
in conservation in ecology
and so obviously when the opening came
up the resident contacted the
Conservation Commission explor expressed
interest the person applied the person
was interviewed by the Conservation
Commission um it was a very productive
um interaction and meeting discussion
questions were answered and as a result
of that
encounter the Conservation Commission
made a recommendation to the select
board highly recommen recommending this
individual there was no no issues no no
questions and furthermore it's my
understanding that this was the only
applicant to fill this vacant
position so without reasonable
explanation um this request for this
member this resident to be appointed it
was denied by the select board and
clearly the decision was not due to a
lack of the candidates
it was because the select board um did
not care for this particular individual
because um for an issue that was
unrelated to the Conservation Commission
the individual in fact was taking
pictures of trees that were being cut
down um on a um project within the town
and was wondering and questioning well
why are these trees being removed there
was no discussion um the proof of
concept renderings showed the trees
there the person was simply asking
questions so um long story short this
incident resulted in this resident not
being appointed to the conservation um
commission by the select board despite
the Conservation Commission members
wanting this person as a result of this
denial the conservation um Commission in
this particular Town ended up having a
vacancy for several
months despite having a person that was
ready willing and able um to to fill
that position wor yet the con the
Conservation Commission really needed
this this this help on their committee
and they had to unnecessarily operate
during a very busy time with four board
members and and not five in some towns
voters might want to have the
Conservation Commission be more
accountable to them the voters when
members are appointed by the select
board there's indirect accountability at
best house bill
1302 provides important enabling
legislation for this option to elect
Conservation Commission members by the
voters a town may choose to adopt
this provision or they can simply stay
with appointing members by the select
board towns can and importantly too
towns can also resend this option or the
decision and they can go back to
appointing members if they so desire
moreover recently in my town where
Brookline War there was warrant articles
to CH to change from appointed um to
elected planning board board members and
also um to change from appointed to
elected zoning board members and in
these past um with more than a two-third
super majority vote and I I say that um
just to to emphasize that these boards
that the land use boards it we have
enabling legislation on the stat on in
statute to allow this to go from
appointed to elected and this bill
simply just allow is um providing the
opportunity for the same procedure
enabling legislation for the
Conservation Commission in some towns um
yeah voters want to be able to directly
decide who serves on these important
boards so um one more point is this year
in Brooklyn the our Conservation
Commission is recommending through the
select board a $4.3 million Bond for
conservation land purchase and our
operating budget is $8 million that's
pretty significant and pretty important
um and um such a purchase has a
significant tax impact so to be very
clear the con the members of that
Conservation Commission they serve a
very important role in local governance
so finally to be clear conservation
Commissions in New Hampshire are
becoming increasingly influential in
important conservation measures some of
which involve significant long-term
purchases therefore having the option to
elect Conservation Commission members is
a very reasonable measure which is why
this bill is very important in closing I
urge the committee to vote the committee
recommendation of ought to pass on this
bill in support of direct accountability
to the voters
in municipalities that choose to adopt
this enabling statute with that I will
you representative Guthrie thank you and
thank you for your testimony I know that
the uh uh elected select board uh
sometime uh inadequate maybe because
they're
elected uh and uh my point is that if if
they act as you have described and the
prime sponsor has described isn't that
correction if there is a need for a
correction made at the polls when the
Selectmen themselves
run thank you for the question
representative I could you please I am
not following your question could you
please restate the question sorry sorry
about that uh don't the uh any
correction because of the actions of the
selectman in the appointing of the
county of the commission uh isn't that
corrected at the
polls by uh the vote that's given to the
Selectmen that are acting in that manner
thank you for the clarification
representative so I sure to be clear
you're saying that if if the
Selectmen you
know don't or or for lack of better
words mess up or or or
don't don't appoint somebody to the
Conservation Commission or or whatever
they they it can be I I guess corrected
um at at the at The Ballot
Box yeah but the PO the point that we're
trying to make here with this
legislation is that that's really that
that's somewhat indirect and and and
that's select boards make many many
decisions and I don't really see with
regards to the Conservation Commission
who who they appoint voters to um take
action based based on
that I think what is important to
understand as I explained in my
testimony it's not this one you
know story or incident that that that
happened in my District you
know that's some evidence but I the
bigger and the the the bigger emphasis
in the more important point is that
conservation commissions are they serve
a very important function and
therefore to provide a enabling
legislation so
that voters if the town so chooses to
have those Conservation Commission
members elected this is just another
tool in the tool box and then and
then members of the Conservation
Commission are directly accountable to
the
voters and I think it's just a better a
better um process Mr chairman to follow
up quickly if I could uh very quickly
and you know the sponsors be is to
be uh gets an adab boy for making it so
uh we have a choice instead of being a
directive but knowing that how important
the con the Conservation Commission is
and how sometimes technical it is as the
sponsor indicated he had the background
and should have been appointed knowing
that how do we justify that anybody can
run for the County Commission whoever
they
are thank you representative uh again at
the end of your question you said
running for County Commissioner I'm
sorry I'm confused yeah I I'm sorry
thank you for picking me up on that but
the fact is that anybody anybody can for
can run for the Conservation Commission
no matter what kind of background they
have and there's no uh double check on
that where there is when the it's
appointed by the SE selectman thank you
thank you representative for the
question my answer to that would be it
it's no different than any other office
every elected office is very important
do you know you could say ask the same
question with regards to the select
board I mean anybody can run for select
board do do they have business
experience do they have a you know
running anything experienced they have
Financial experience at So my answer to
to to all of that would be when a person
runs there's interaction with the voters
you know they campaign there's websites
there's forums there's debates all that
can be uncovered and discovered during
that process representative
Elward thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my
question um I'm new to local control so
correct me if I'm wrong but
under line
13 when the town has adopted the
provisions to make this possible
is it not the selectman that
would recommend an article to
adopt thank you for the question
representative so if this is enabling
statute there's two ways that this could
get on the the warrant the first would
be the the selectman could be asked or
for lack of a better word petitioned by
the voters in in the town to place this
enabling statute on on the warrant and
secondly the legislature in its
um what's the word I'm looking for
wisdom thank you in its wisdom has
allowed um the citizens to put warrants
on the ballot through a process called a
petition to Warrant article I've been
there thank
you major thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question um have
you contacted the New Hampshire
Association of conservation commissions
and and if so did they have any input
thank you thank you representative thank
you for the question so um I am a i a
co-sponsor of this legislation and I
have personally not contacted that
agency are the questions representative
yella thank you thank you for taking the
question you keep on talking about
accountability and um are
you is it your belief that this this
legislation is um important because of
the uh requirement in article 8 of The
Constitution that requires the
government be open and accessible and
accountable to the people of the that
they serve thank you representative
thank you for the question um in my mind
this enabling um legislation like I said
is another tool another option and to me
it's it and it allows the
voters more direct I guess democracy if
you would by being able to vote and
Commission representative Gilman thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative
um conservation commissions have their
own chapter unlike the planning board
zba Etc
um and those other bodies
are uh regulatory they can make their
own subdivisions and uh and the zba has
you know the zoning ordinance but the
Conservation
Commission is made to
um oversee and uh maintain Etc but they
can't make a
decision about to purchase or whatever
piece of property without the governing
body and so my question is um and maybe
this applies to all the land use boards
but uh would you expect to find uh
regular amount of people who are willing
to um run for an election and pay money
for what is a volunteer job given New
Hampshire's run by volunteers
thank you for the question
representative uh it's unclear to me um
what what your referencing with regards
to paying money um in my district the Lo
local races nobody um pays money to to
per I I I assume that you're perhaps
referencing like to run a campaign
um that just doesn't happen and you know
in my um District so I don't have um
that's I can only answer it to that
degree and so I think the question to me
that you're asking is would there be a
problem
with having um people run and I would
say no and again I would remind the
committee that this is enabling
legislation if a particular Town didn't
want it didn't think it was good then
there's no obligation to to adopt this
the for example I all
right you answered the question very
well thank you further questions seeing
none I have one representative I know
you'll know the answer to this uh back
as many others have mentioned line 15
and 16 the select May remove the elected
member for cause um it's been said that
some of the other committees that are
elected the Selectmen have that
could you point me to the AR just for my
personal U edification point me to the
RSA where that happens and the only
reason I ask that is I find
it
almost antithetical to an election to be
to have one body be able to remove
another body and if that exists already
that might require some future
legislation thank you for the question
so you're asking so to be clear I didn't
write this bill OS drafted the bill
additionally I'm not the prime sponsor
however I do understand that this the
language for this this bill is mirrors
the language the enabling statute for
planning boards and the zba so I would
refer you to to those statutes and
unfortunately I don't have those
memorized thank you representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so to follow up
if I may on uh the chair's
question
so an elected official put into office
under the terms of this enabling
legislation is answerable to the people
who elected him or her by virtue of the
fact that they were elected yet once
that elected official is in office they
could be be removed by the same nasty
select board that didn't want them to be
there in the first place then what would
be the point of electing them at all
well thank you for the question
representative again I would refer you
to the fact that this bill mirrors the
language for this bill was taken
directly from the other
statutes with regards to the other local
land use board so I think if you're
going to ask the question then that's a
question that should apply to all three
um
boards follow
up then I'll go back to my original
question to representative sellers which
is why does this only apply to the
Conservation
Commission thank you for the question I
I don't understand um the
question why does this bill only mention
mention the Conservation Commission if
it follows that the other boards are
under the same rule I apologize I I I'm
not follow following the line of
question you're asking why is this bill
only pertain to the Conservation
Commission in in what context are you
asking that question I it B basically I
think the answer to the question would
be it pertains to this because it
pertains to this it's the conserv
composition of the Conservation
Commission it it
there the sponsors have not taken upon
themselves to go into other sections
they're specifically focusing on
Conservation Commission whether that's
right or wrong I guess I that would be
the answer represent FR yes thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um is it true that
the ZB ba and planning boards currently
can be either appointed or
elected they thank you for the question
representative I believe that is true
because we there's enabling legislation
I mean statute so they can be appointed
or they could be elected yeah followup
Mr chair go ahead uh do you happen to
know any historical background as to why
the Conservation Commission is appointed
rather
than elected up to up to the point of
your bill thank you for the question
not represent
Gallagher um so to go a bit more into
the part about the select board removing
them uh what I'm thinking of is the
parallels between that and
impeachment um where other elected
bodies can remove someone from another
Branch but um with cases of impeachment
it's usually a 2third super majority so
what would you think would would you be
open to maybe say um remov by a with a
super majority vote or something for the
um removal
provision thank you for the question
representative um it appears to me that
this
this this sentence here is causing
confusion so I I am open
to as a co-sponsor I would be open to an
amendment that would rectify the
confusion I would also note that it does
say after a public
hearing representative Elward thank you
Mr chairman um
representative under 673 colon 13
removal of
members it allows for uh an elected
member to be removed by the board of
Selectmen after a public
hearing for causes
enumerated in uh Roman 1 which
are inefficiency neglect of Duty or
malfeasance in office do you believe
that
this was what
um line 15 and
16 was referencing or or used as a model
thank you for the question
representative um again I didn't draft
this bill OLS did and I'm not the prime
sponsor but it is my understanding that
it was the intent was to model so that
we have
consistency after the other um enabling
statute so if you're telling me that
negligence malfeasance and inefficiency
are listed out specifically then I I I
would prefer that that would be listed
out specifically and not replaced by
four cause because clearly those three
reasons are very specific and I would
prefer that for the most part or when um
when it makes sense to have things
consistent
thank
you sen
Brown just quickly representative thank
you Mr chairman
um do you think the language that was
written by OS um as far as for cause was
a specific legal
definition thank you for the question
representative I have I I
can't I can't comment as to the thought
process um I'm not an attorney so we
somebody would have to follow up with
OSS and ask that specific pointed
question representative Holland you had
your hand up before uh actually my
question was kind of answered was like
it was that's fine very good further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony I have one
RoR
thank you members of the committee for
the opportunity to comment on House Bill
1302 my name is Barbara RoR I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
Association of conservation commissions
um for those of you who don't know who
nhacc is we are a nonprofit organization
we serve 217 Municipal conservation
commissions here in New Hampshire we
support commissions so that they can be
successful and protecting their local
natural resources we give them the tools
they need so that they can go back to
their communities and do all this good
work and we are opposed to House Bill
1302 because we believe that overall it
will um reduce the number of willing
volunteers to serve in these committees
and we we understand that it's an
optional process but it there's some
complications in this that maybe I'll
I'll kind of go through as we as I go
further but first I'd like to just
highlight conservation commissions and
they play an important role in their
local communities they're charged with
the protection of natural resources and
Water Resources in their communities and
most governing bodies in New Hampshire
take this responsibility very serious
and they follow the intent of
36a conservation commissions are taking
the lead on land conservation projects
coordinating everything from purchase
and sale to
fundraising and thanks to conservation
commissions cities and towns are now
using sophisticated technology to
identify their critical natural
resources for protection in their Master
plans and conservation plans volunteers
are on the ground maintaining Trails
managing invasive species and showcasing
best management practices um on land
conservation and town forests so that
their neighbors can um learn by
example um New Hampshire conservation
commissions are active in their
communities Ed with uh educational
programs and Hikes to help citizens
better understand the benefits of
protecting their natural environment so
they do provide a per important public
service to their communities New
Hampshire would not have the same level
of Clean Water fresh air and protected
natural habitat um without Municipal
conservation Comm commissions who care
so deeply for their
communities
um
and Conservation Commission members
simply want to do their part for their
environment and their Community um and
this is often a welcome service in most
most towns and so one of our greatest
concerns with this bill is that it would
lead to a lower number of local
Conservation Commission
volunteers um and I again we understand
that it's optional but it could kind of
snowball out of control if if towns you
know um if you know if it does become
the the option for
towns so I know that the uh volunteers
that I've talked with are not interested
in running for a camp running a campaign
for election um and they in many towns
it does cost a lot of money and time to
become elected and so there is that
concern there that we would be losing
some good people who just would not want
to go through that process um and it and
it seems like an additional layer for
for a
volunteer um we want citizens appointed
to conservation commissions who are
willing to do the work and not simply
because they're popular in town or
because their name is easily
recognized and another piece that's
important to consider is that
relationship with their select board and
I and I know that can be you know may
not always be smooth and and run easily
but um because the con the select board
is responsible for in appointing the
Conservation Commission members they
typically have a better understanding of
those
those members they they know what their
um interests are and they have a better
kind of working relationship with them
because they've they have chosen them to
be on those commissions and and because
I I think another important thing to
consider here is that the Conservation
Commission is advisory um and that was
brought up before so in order for
commissions to be successful they need
to work closely with their planning
board and their select board so we do
want volun who can work with other
people and who can um you know work with
their select board and they they need to
get along every year at our our
conference we have a workshop on working
with other boards because we believe
that's that's how we you know New
Hampshire runs we work together we get
things done so I don't know if that that
would work so well if someone's just
elected um and I also want to clarify
that conservation commissions are not
land use boards because they're advisory
they do not um approve or deny permits
there's no regulatory role that they
have like a land use board planning
board or zba so they don't really follow
the same structure as those other land
use boards so just to clarify they're
not a land use
board um and and I also want to let you
know that many towns have instituted a a
very thorough interview process for
appointments um they often require
resums or
applications um many commission members
are initially appointed as alternates so
they gain experience before they become
um voting members and um most
municipalities do rely on
recommendations from conservation
commissions for those new members it is
certainly an unfortunate story and that
may happen from time to time that the
select board doesn't take a
recommendation from a Conservation
Commission but I from what I've seen
that's that's rare and typically not the
case and if it if it is the case you
know we need to work on it we need to
figure that out so I I ask that you
don't threaten this thoughtful local
process that's currently in place
there's really no guarantee or evidence
that elections would result in a more
capable or committed group of local
conservation
volunteers um New Hampshire's required
the election of Conservation Commission
members um and this is not a practice in
other states as well um and it's mainly
because they're advisory um New
Hampshire's enabling legislation for
Conservation Commission commissions was
passed in
1963 and New Hampshire Conservation
commissions have been successfully
protecting clean water fresh air and
natural habitat for 60 years so we
respectfully vote ask you to vote in
expedient to legislate on House Bill
1302 and I'd be happy to answer any
questions you may
have thank you very much for your
testimony representative Elward thank
you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony today um it's my understanding
there's
municipalities in the state how many of
those um municipalities have
conservation commissions thank you for
the question um I believe there's 23 4
towns in New Hampshire um and 217 of
those towns have conservation
commissions and about 195 of those Town
those commissions are members of the New
Hampshire Association of conservation
commissions follow up go
ahead thank you Mr chairman do you think
um the difference between 234 and
27 might have something to do with types
the complaints we've heard today that
perhaps
um there's a barrier somehow that this
bill is trying to
fix I I mean it does sound like there
have been issues for certain towns and I
you know I in some cases I'm not
surprised I mean it's a tough uh
position to be on a select board and to
appoint members and um you know I think
it doesn't always work so we need to be
aware of that and and try our best to to
solve it but we believe
actually you know the current process
works
and the the proposed um proposing
elections I think is kind of would have
more unintended consequences than we'd
be prepared to to deal with
representative majori thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking a
question which is just clarification I
was writing something else down did you
say that did did I hear correctly that
no other no other surrounding States
elect that's correct no other um
surrounding States elect their
Conservation Commission members thank
you
Guthrie thank you thank you Mr chairman
thanks for your your testimony I happen
to be a leon to my Conservation
Commission and would you say it's fair
it's fair to say that not only do the
selectman appoint the Conservation
Commission me members but they they have
a close relationship as they go forward
doing their job yes I would say ideally
they do have a close uh working
relationship with their commission
members and again it's important because
commissions are advisory so if they want
to achieve goals they really need the
support of Select board and planning
board to to um you know move certain
projects forward thank you thank you Mr
chairman representative Gallagher
uh so I heard uh two separate claims in
there one um that it will
make um make it harder to find
volunteers for this position and two
that
um people um R running in elections
would have to raise more money which
they might want to do but don't you kind
of think those two claims are intention
with one another like if you're the only
one running would you really have to
raise money then like I was on a post in
my last election and didn't raise
it I I mean that's it's certainly
possible that you would not need to
spend money to run an election you know
to run for Conservation Commission
member but I do know in many communities
it can be expensive and that was my only
point that it can be expensive can be
time consum time consuming and I believe
it would be um detrimental to a certain
number of volunteers that wouldn't want
to go through that
process further
questions seeing none I have two quick
ones um you mentioned no other states
surrounding states have uh elected
conservation commissions are there any
states that do that not that I'm aware
of so um okay it's mostly a New England
thing um other states have more of what
you'd consider Conservation District or
environmental
commissions okay thank you um the second
one you mentioned a couple of times that
this is enabling but you could see this
quote snowballing out of control could
you give me a very simplified example of
how it would snowball out of control
sure um I I think you know while it
could often get good um members in there
um talented um
thoughtful um Conservation Commission
members I believe it could also uh run
in the opposite direction where you
could um elect members who aren't really
interested in protecting natural
resources who may um you know have an
opposing view of what the commission
should be working on um and and and I
think my other main concern though
really when I say snowball is that you
know we'd have you know a select board
here and a commission here and they
would not be working together and then
you would really be very ineffective so
that that's my main concern when I say
snowballs you're going to have these two
different boards and they're not going
to work together and basically they
won't be
effective thank you further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
uh we have thank you very much blue
sheet we have one individual signed in
against and that was it on the blue
sheet seeing no more pink cards close
the hearing on HB 1302 we are scheduled
to be back at 1:30 for what will be a
very interesting
then
twoed
yeah
e
minutes the
what that's why I use
it
stop
all right good afternoon everybody
welcome back we're going to go ahead and
open up the public hearing on hb14 1414
relative to the gun stock area
commission and ski
resort and I see the prime sponsor is
floor
thank you Mr chair good afternoon
members of the
committee my name is uh representative
Barbara compa belnap 7 for the
record this bill
covers addresses three different
situations um and I'll just do a quick
overview and then I'll expound on each
of them the first one is to
increase the amount of Revenue that the
county receives from Gunstock from
1.75% to
3% the second section is regarding
meetings and the third section is
requiring forensic
audit I'll speak to the first
part when this we went to this form of
contribution to from Gunstock to the
county the original bill was going to
ask for 5%
um and it was decided upon at that time
1.75% uh to get a 100% Buy in but at the
time when I spoke to the prime sponsor
of this bill several of the sponsors um
that have now sent in letters to this
that we're asking for this
increase
because
Gunstock is an asset of the county it is
the county
stock and it is the county
taxpayers that if gun stock defaults on
anything it is them that has to pick up
the
tab and that has happened in the
past
dollars so I am coming here for a modest
increase of
1.25% of gross
income
section being subject to 91a public
meetings shall be recorded you will hear
testimony that they have since the
current Commissioners have put that in
policy however policies can be changed
policies do not have to be adhered to
this is a public mountain and again it
is owned by the county
taxpayers and
therefore it should be in statute that
all meetings except those that are not
recorded and then the final section the
forensic
audit the reason I'm bringing this forth
and asking for it to be put
in statute is
one yes can we ask for a forensic audit
of Gunstock yes is it subject to
politics yes is it subject to the whim
of whoever's on the delegation
yes I have had experience at the county
level when we wanted to do a forensic
audit and was met
with you know you're accusing us of
wrongdoing a forensic audit is not
accusing anyone of
wrongdoing it is about keeping honest
people
honest and then at the county level when
we decided Well we won't you don't want
a forensic audit we do an audit
committee they then asked us to do a
forensic
audit I mean that's how it's played out
in politics
right at Gunstock we're asking for a
forensic audit to be done once every
five years not every year but twice a
decade and that would be a random year
the first year to be audited would be
2021 part of the reason for this is
that what we found at Gunstock and that
the traditional audit never caught was
political contributions being
made by the
mountain that is taxpayer money whether
you're a Democrat or
Republican your County government should
not be giving money to political
candidates
it was a public citizen that found this
era and it had been going on for
decade the other thing you have to
done it doesn't look it looks at certain
criteria it doesn't look at
everything and it's also they put out
questions they ask for certain
information and if they can only go on
the information
given and I can let you know that I
originally I was assigned to an audit
Gunstock it was disbanded pretty
quickly but what I did discover in that
short
time was that all the information that
the Auditors asked for was not giving to
them and I am quoting directly from the
meeting that I was on a phone call with
with the
Auditors there are only two check
signers and you you will hear that now
the commission now is looking at the
check register but a check register
really doesn't do a whole
lot it doesn't look at the small dollar
amounts it doesn't look at the checks
that had no endorsements on the back of
them that were cash at other
Banks this is what I
discovered and I think it would be in
the best interest of the county
taxpayers to have this
done I'm not saying that any wrongdoing
has been
done
but it could someone
could someone may have we don't know it
has never been done we know that they
wrote checks out for political
contributions and no one caught it for
years I will I will take any questions
that the committee may
have thank you for the testimony
representative
majority thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question uh just for
clarity looking in in section three
where you asked for the forensic audit
to go back to
2021 and and if I heard you correctly it
was because there were political
contributions that were made uh but this
is where I want to get the clarity you
said going back at least a
decade um and I just looked up real
quick how many Republican versus
Democrats so it seems like if that is if
that is true the contributions would
have been going to um uh candidates from
both parties and I'm wondering if you
know what the Attorney General's opinion
is on those contributions being made if
those indeed were being made to both
parties does that make the question make
any sense thank you for your question
and yes I can tell you that a cease and
assist letter by the Attorney General
was given to uh Tom
day
and the commissioner said well we put it
in our policy that that can't happen
you repr with Holland thank you um so
you mentioned a forensic audit once
every five years currently does Gunstock
or I mean I assume that uh in terms of
uh your towns there I don't know how it
works because it's County wise are
conducting a yearly audit anyway that
has you know focuses really on the
financial control systems to stop a lot
of what you're talking about is that
actually occurring are you doing a
yearly audit for the county thank you
thank you representative yes Gunstock is
required to have a yearly audit but as I
stated a yearly audit doesn't delve into
things um it's re they're based on what
is given to to them what they've
requested and what has been given to
minutia representative uh
kill thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um you testified that
specific political candidates had
received contributions from from
Gunstock can can you comment to which
political candidates those
were uh thank you for the question uh to
the best of my knowledge they were
candidates for
Governor
representative
Elward thank you Mr chairman and
welcome um do you know the cost of a
forensic
audit uh thank you for the question so a
forensic audit can go anywhere from
$5,000 to about
$50,000 but if you a averaged a at the
top end that would be about $110,000 per
year if you ACR that
expense thank you representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question um so how is the 3%
number to to go from 1.75 to
3% uh thank you for that question um
during the original B bill it was always
intended to come back and revisit it
that amount and originally I thought
about going to the 5% that we originally
going to do back when we first filed
this method of payment but
um I figured a modest increase of
1.25% was a better
approach um and please note that there's
you know if they do well the county does
well if they don't do well the county
you know it's reliant on how well
Gunstock does thank you follow up
followup go ahead so is the Gunstock
county thank you for the question and
that is the million dooll question it is
a county-owned asset beloved by I'd say
everybody in in the county I mean my
kids and I both learn to uh snowboard
there um every enjoys it it's beautiful
um but you have to understand that it is
the county
taxpayers that are on the hook if
Gunstock ever defaults on
anything so yes could it be a profit
Center but we're also um the the so the
county taxpayers should be the
recipient of when they do well and when
they don't do well well we have end up
paying the
bill thank
you representative of power thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question with regards to the profit the
profits of
Gunstock are you aware or do you know
how the profits if there have been any
in the past years how are they how was
that money
used um some of it's reinvested back
into the mountain obviously they use it
for operating
expenses the county does
enjoy uh this year we we got over
$300,000
but we've also given Gunstock over a
million dollars in Opera funds for
Capital
Improvements and we have given
Gunstock a lot of dollars in the past
for
defaults so I can't go into that but I
am sure that there are many folks behind
me that will give you a better answer
than
I representative elt thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question regarding uh the second issue
about meetings to be recorded did you
say that they already they currently are
recording uh thank you for the question
yes this current uh border Commissioners
did put into a policy that they record
the Gunstock
meetings but it is only a policy which
means they do not have to if they don't
want to thank
you
representative correct thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um on the subject of your
contribution to the county uh I'm not
sure that I understand why it's based on
the gross operating or the gross revenue
less uh donations and
grants um rather than
um your quote profit after
expenses could you please explain why
that uh the
rationale thank you for the question
representative well the reason it went
because there was a lot of questions uh
in the previous years with uh use meming
of understandings um with what actual
profit
was um did it
include uh the depreciation which is a
non-cash item was it uh how was it
accounted for did we move things around
to make it look like there was a less
profit I am not suggesting that that was
done but if you use depreciation and
amortization and you deduct that from
your
profit you're you're that is a non-cash
item that does that would have a drastic
effect on what is given to the
county followup Please Mr chair go ahead
um so if let's say for example this
year um you had to replace a ski
lift your profit would be wiped out but
you but you did have enough money to
replace that ski lift would you then
still owe the
uh thank you for the
question so we have a formula here um
Gunstock has been thriving for the past
few few years um but in previous years
before that they used to come to the
county and ask for a for for better
terms a loan um and the county taxpayers
or the delegation would grant that loan
so that it would tie them over until
they got into the winter season and
started with their operating revenues
again but they're like I
said uh they haven't done that for a
while but it is the county taxpayers no
matter how you slice this that is
responsible for the debts of Gunstock if
cash represent Elward thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question over the last decade let's say
approximately has the
gross revenue increased or decreased on
average I would say uh thank you for the
question again um I would say under the
increased the
questions seeing none I have one
representative um looking at your bill
items number two and three
on the bill starting uh two starting at
line 10 three starting at 14 are those
new new
sections thank you Mr chair yes they
would be new
sections okay because the the way the uh
just for your information the way the
bill is drafted it
doesn't note that you we have the top
part which is amended but it doesn't
mention that the bottom two are actually
new Just for information I appreciate
that
okay thank you very much for your
much okay we're going to go down the
list of we got many reps who are going
to be testifying so we'll go down the
line here representative
bogert also I'd remind everybody when
they uh speak start out by let letting
us know whether you're for or against we
know on the pink cards the people in the
audience may not know thank you or the
you thank you Mr
chairman uh chairman Lynn turot on
December 14 2023 the bellnap county
delegation met at this meeting public
input and delegation discussion was
taken on hb1 1414
dfn the summary of this was the
delegation voted to recommend
itl for hb1 1414 FM the motion passed
with a bipartisan vote of 11 to four
eight Republicans three Democrats being
four and four Republicans being
against public input from uh from the
public with one person speaking the
chairman of the Gunstock area commission
which will be speaking in a few minutes
um provided their thoughts on this bill
and his thoughts were I'm going to make
a synopsis you can go into it in deeper
terms to increase the percentage payable
to the bellnap county of
1.75% of gross revenues to 3% of gross
revenues could put undue Financial
pressure on Gunstock Mountain Resort
this could impact employment maintenance
and future projects secondly as a
fingent atic the delegation AR already
retains the right by vote to request a
forensic audit and lastly the guny area
committee also records their meetings so
all aspects of this bill are
currently uh taking
place and
as the uh sponsor of the bill indicated
that even though they were policies
instituted by the
committee and that the committee could
change it well we all sit here changing
rsas also so as one cycle we can change
in RSA the next cycle we can change in
RSA again so but the we don't set up
policies and stuff with the intent of
knowing that we're going to change it we
do this with the goodness of knowing
that we want to fulfill something that
the general public finds is needed in
which case the Gunstock committee itself
indicated it was needed to so that bnap
tape
so the delegation discussion the
delegation agreed that increasing the
percentage payable to belck County from
1.75% of gross
revenue and I want I just want to make a
comment with the gross revenues think
about any company that you would say I
want to take
1.75% right off the
top Le on now I want to take 3% % right
off the top and think about how would a
company survive knowing right out of the
gross before you buy any more equipment
before you buy or pay for your labor
your health care or anything else you're
going to take this right off the top so
if that's not a crippling effect I'm not
quite sure what what would
be
um now we also have I don't think
anybody's from the counties here the
county also had a meeting the Board of
Commissioners and they also
voted in their meeting to
itl so the the County Commission itself
does not support this bill in any aspect
whatsoever
the county delegation does not support
this bill in
any
fashion and I'm gonna let the the uh
commissioner is here for Gunstock and
I'll let him speak for
himself
so the forensic AIT itself as we did
have one and it did show there was uh
one adjustment that needed and and the
letter was written and that has been
taken care of that was the uh
$5,000 checks that were written for uh
whoever's campaign it was it was written
to and by the end of it all being done
it was an over a
$50,000
$5,000 done now to me I'm not quite sure
that's a good return on your investment
as a county taxpayer
because the taxpayer was on the hook for
all of this money so as we keep trying
to save our our taxpayer by charging
them more
money for something that can be done by
the
delegation
anyway so with that I'm done and I'm
questions representative power thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I missed what you did you say
that the
donations the improper
donations that were made through to the
to the governor race did you was not
determined to be improper until after
the Attorney General's office did the
research and stuff the verbiage that was
in all of the documents that were
available at that time left it unclear
that's why the yearly audits missed it
because it was unclear that they were
actually doing something wrong there was
nothing phous going on there was nothing
to where they were intentionally trying
to take tax taxpayers money and and give
it away uh to candidates and stuff it
was the way the paperwork was the
Attorney General's office made their
determination they sent the letter and
it's been corrected since then yes
follow go ahead thank you Mr chair
um that was an answer to a question I
kind I wasn't asking I was trying to
find out how much money had been
donated this was to cover a $5,000
that's all I was thank you for verifying
that
thanks excuse me representative kill
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question we heard previous testimony
that the payments went on for a decade
so if it went on for 10 years wouldn't
that be
$50,000 I'm
not aware of of how much that is uh over
the years but it was not hidden to the
fact quick quick followup go ahead do
you think it's appropriate for any
taxpayer dollars to be going towards a
candidate no I do not and that is why
it's been rectified when this was
brought to everybody's attention it has
been
rectified representative Gilman thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um in the uh letter of
testimony from the Gunstock area
commission they refer to an amount that
was actually borrowed from the county um
as a revenue anticipation note do you
know I I'm assuming but do you know uh
that that Revenue anticipation note was
paid because it's in anticipation of
getting the revenue in a seasonal place
is going to anticipate getting Revenue
at a these notes have all been paid back
there was nothing held onto the
taxpayers
uh coughers to do this and then actually
it was a bond they covered a bond to
give them through to the point where
they can uh operate into this and the
last several years they have uh improved
themselves so that they have not had to
bonds representative PR again thank you
Mr chair uh thank you for taking my
question previous testimony I believe
indicated that there were one or more
defaults on money lent from the county
can you elaborate on that for us I'm not
aware of any defaults um I'm sure the uh
committee chairman and Dom delay who
might be speaking also would be able to
question okay seeing no more questions
thank you for your testimony
representative bogert uh just for those
in the audience uh so you're aware we go
through the representatives first before
we uh go to anybody else besides a rep
mcarter
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
I'm getting over a sinus infection so I
don't always sound like this sound kind
of like a robot um I don't really have
anything to contribute with regards to
questions about the financial health or
uh non-health about the Gunstock
Mountain what I can contribute is for
some reason Gunstock is a political
lightning rod you are probably all very
well aware of this um um in my opinion
being a county owned facility like
Gunstock is it should be a revenue
Center not a profit Center and I think
that is a huge distinction that needs to
be made so I don't believe that the
3% uh that this bill States uh would
come back to the county is a lot to ask
when my property tax is living in belnap
County are approaching $10,000 a year
for a very modest home at and I'm not
alone there so I think the uh newspapers
up there touting how successful and
wonderful Gunstock is it's a valuable
resource for anyone to come to it really
is it's a beautiful place uh if it's
there truly for the benefit of belnap
County then the profits should be sent
back to the residents of belnap County
so thank you for your time any questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony uh next up representative
Harvey
bolier thank you Mr chair and thank you
members of the municipal committee my
name is representative Juliet Harvey
bully I represent home in samton for the
record in Bop County and um I'm uh
speaking against the bill and I won't
take up too much of your time because
the main reason is uh we haven't had a
chance or opportunity to discuss this in
our delegation meetings so we we have
not um debated this issue we haven't um
discussed different percentages and I'm
not um particularly opposed to changing
the amount either but I think it's um
probably the most prudent thing to do
would be for um us delegates to come
together discuss the changes the pro the
cons and and how it should should be
dealt with over the long term 10 years
or so um you've got to weigh things like
uh
weather um years where Gunstock is going
to have fewer
profits there's so many different
variables that we really need to discuss
um and and that is how we came to you
know what it how the law is written
today and the amount the percentage that
is currently um on the record uh a
number of years ago representative Dum
reminded us um that we got together that
the delegation got together and really
worked very hard to come up with the 1%
that's in the law that's written as it
is today and it came about as a as quite
a bit of hard work uh that the whole
delegation was involved in and um I
think you know that that is
going to be the wisest way forward is
for us to decide as a delegation and
then come to you folks in committee
unless of course you would like to see
us back every single year with changes
to this percentage going up and down and
um that is my biggest argument against
the bill as it as is as it is written
today is that it was not a product of
the delegation as a whole uh and I just
wanted to also say that representative
Harry Bean who's the chair would like to
be here he asked me to at tell you that
he is opposed to the bill and he has uh
submitted written testimony to that
effect um and other than that um thank
you for your time unless you have any
questions representative
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I need some
clarification so in your your testimony
you stated that the the belnap county
delegation had not had the opportunity
to discuss this bill and the issue here
at hand however as a Committee Member I
I have a letter that says that on
December
14th
2023 that the bellnap county delegation
both discussed and voted on a
recommendation with regards to this bill
and it was signed by the chair of the
Bell County delegation so I'm just
confused as to what actually took place
and in your statement did you means what
did you mean by your statement thank you
very much um for allowing me to clarify
that um I believe I said it's not a the
the uh the 3% for instance the the
verbiage in the bill was not a product
of a subcommittee or any sort of um it
was never even on the agenda prior to
the time that we voted so we knew that
um the committee was going to hear the
the we didn't have time
to uh even talk about amendments we
simply took a vote because of the
upcoming hearing um but in years
past rep according to representative D
who was there at the time a couple terms
back he said that the whole delegation
had work worked on it for instance in a
subcommittee although I I'm not sure if
it was a subcommittee at the time but I
can get that information and it took it
sounded like several months to come up
still representative
Gallagher so you mentioned
um that the delegation had had a chance
to um give feedback on it uh so I'm
wondering is is that something the
bellat county delegation normally does
about legislation because at least in my
County delegation the mar County
delegation I can't remember ever having
had a time where we've voted on
legislation that was than to be
considered by the rest of the house we
generally just stick to the
budget um stuff so can you um tell me
what you mean
[Music]
there um I'll do my best I'm I'm I think
the question is have we ever discussed
things before as a delegation as far
as statutory law law that's going to be
heard is that the
question um yeah basically is this is
this normal PR would doing so be normal
practice for your
delegation um thank you for that um I
know we have not um to be honest excuse
me we haven't uh discussed anything but
there was a bill before your committee
last year I believe it had to do with
term uh length of term for Sheriff's the
sheriff's
uh um position and I think one of the
reasons and I'm just guessing one of the
reasons it it didn't pass is because we
didn't have any kind of opinion from the
county the county didn't decide on this
and then present it to Municipal now I
could be that is just the uh the Scuttle
butt I heard about that but I I think
it's personally I think it's a good
practice and I'm hoping that moving
moving forward with our County
delegation if we have such um
legislation going forward that we all
get the opportunity to address it and
put it on the agenda at least and um
discuss it it would be nice to have a
vote before we go and um bring it
presented to the municipal committee and
and take up your valuable
time thank
you further questions representative
kahill
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I was I was just looking
some for some clarification on
representative Po's question I I was
going to ask the same question we just
heard testimony from the previous um
gentleman that you guys met and voted on
it as a delegation to decide whether or
not this should go
forward and I guess my question is what
did you vote on did did you look at the
vote um thank you for the question
representative K Hill uh we didn't
really de I mean to my recollection we
did not uh
debate the merits of the bill the bill
was the language was passed
out um and yes we did discuss the
procedure for the vote what it meant we
uh didn't discuss it in in depth um but
it was you know obviously it's presented
and and we V voted on it but it was
rather quick because as I said before we
knew that it was coming before the
committee and it would be wises to make
a a
recommendation um to present to your
committee but no we we've never had it
on an agenda formally in our delegation
and we certainly didn't debate
on um what sort
of percentage would be appropriate what
are some of the long-term impacts um are
we going to make this change every year
seasonally or are we going to um is
gunar going to have a bad year and then
we're going to have a new um percentage
to bring before the um committee is it
going to go like that every few years we
change so we didn't uh it was it was
pretty cursory I have to to say I hope
that answers your
question representative
yella thank you
thank you for taking the question um
prior to the legislation being submitted
did you are you aware of any
subcommittee or any work by the
committee s the passage of the original
1.75%
to uh consider updating that um based on
additional information or um are you
essentially waiting for for for the the
state to decide make movement on that
before you take any action thank you um
thank you representative yella um
I'm uh I'm not aware of um first we
didn't even I didn't even see because
the bill was um the verbiage of the bill
wasn't available for quite a while it
was um is we knew that there was a bill
uh to do with an LSR to do with gun
stock but we we couldn't actually read
it um so we got that fairly late in the
game and I am not aware of anything I'm
only aware that a couple terms back
representative D said that they as a
delegation worked on it at length
perhaps over a number of months to come
up with the
1.75% and then since then it's never
been raised in delegation like let's
change
it uh you you know it was never on the
agenda at all or discussed in any way
that I have any uh Rec recollection
of thank you further
questions see none I have one
representative U twice you mentioned the
1% that's currently in the law what
figure were you uh referring
to the I think I think it's
1.75% is crossed
out the the current LA understood you
twice I heard you say 1% though so I was
just making sure there was some not not
another number you were referring to so
you were referring to 1.75 I was yes I'm
sorry further questions Hy seeing none
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much uh representative uh
representative
PL thank you chair in the committee uh I
am foror record representing Tom PL from
belnap 1 representing the constituents
of my towns of Center Harbor in New
Hampton uh I'm here to speak on the
forensic audit of this bill I'm in
elected why do we get elected I went
around told my experience I have life
experience part of it I just want to
share with you real quick
coming from coming from Connecticut
until I retired in 2008 to New Hampshire
I've been involved with the first
responder
Triad uh with the fire um mostly with
the ambulance working with fire and the
town and the
police so what I'm going to share with
you today
is since I left in
2011 two people have been charged and
convicted with felonies of
embezzlement one person working with him
as he was an instructor this is all
Connecticut as a EMT instructor he
became the town Plymouth Connecticut
$800,000 in three years
yes it was
caught the thing and once again the
second gentleman was with the Fire
Department volunteer fire of the town he
only embezzled
also as we know I'm
assuming things happened
that we don't know why without a
forensic
it we would not find out why we have
audits if the
delegation wishes to call one and they
did call one and it was a big uproar
personalities politics everything got
involved by putting in statute
eliminates all of that it's there it's
an arbitary year they
pick and going
forward the delegation still can call an
audit if it needs it to be within the 5
years something else happens but I've
seen the politics I've seen the personal
um attacks from both sides on calling it
audit you bring in people you elected or
appointed to
it where and basically that's the whole
jits from life experience and once again
the gun stock area you probably
heard the
expenditures are equivalent or real
close to the whole County's expenditure
it's not a little little bit of money
that's handled right now there's no
Treasurer
um and I'm not even going to say who
does the books I'm not sure my point is
my life
experience we don't think it's going to
happen New Hampshire I didn't think it
was going to happen in my small town of
Plymouth by people I actually knew
why do you why do we need to put it on
the delegation to go through this whole
political um
charade with the public and
everything if there is another audit
someone thinks needed once again to
summarize in statute it will be there it
doesn't have to be five years that's
could be amended in my part just so the
people who are handling the money knows
that somewhere there's a mechanism
that's going to pull up a a year within
those five years and take a look at the
books um that's
about my end of it and I'm willing to
take questions thank you thank you for
your testimony questions representative
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question my question is
with regards to this um required
mandated forensic audit are you aware of
any other areas of our New Hampshire
statute
that requires a similar forensic audit
and the second qu part of that is just
confirm that the commission Gunstock
commission is going to pay for this
audit If This Were to become
law if I understand it right um I don't
have the RSA in front of me but the
county
delegation has a statute to call for
Audits and the second part I believe is
I think the audit is by excuse
me it's going to be by Statute and the
auditor would pick a year
chosen do you have a follow-up
representative thank thank you
representative um I'll restate my
question and I'll just I'll just keep it
to one
so my I'm curious to to to know and to
understand do you know if there's any
other
areas I'll I'll withdraw my
question may
I representative major thank you Mr
chairman and thank you taking my
question and and just so I'm clear and
want to see if you understand it the
same way the audit can go back to
2016 correct because it says in order to
be clear that it shall start in the year
2021 and include any 5-year period
previously and therefore if I read the
plain language your friend a AIT of a
random year in the preceding five years
and the first year is 2021 that it can
go back to 2016 or what's 21 minus
5 hold on wait a minute carry the
[Laughter]
and yes to your question yes it it could
go back five years but that's how it's
introduced I I leave it up it's in your
hands if it needs to be changed to
eliminate the pass and start fresh if if
that's how the committee wishes to go um
I don't see anything wrong but yes one
year within those six yes it could go
back back to something that has been
addressed
already and this committee does have the
experience to decide which way it should
go when it should
start further
questions seeing none thank you
representative for your testimony and
day
um if he wants
to what was his
name um he may speak before you but in
order of what I had here the next person
up will be the honorable Mike Sylvia and
then I'll have him speak yes and he can
you
thank you Mr chairman my name is Mike
Sylvia I'm from the town of Belmont
repres representing myself I am former
representative for five terms and former
delegation we're here today
because there was a problem a couple
years ago in the summer of 22 that's
when things came to a
boil and one of the gentlemen that's
going to speak to you next and you can
have some questions for
him prior contrary to his
contract walked out of his job as the
CEO president of Gunstock Mountain
resort with him
coincidentally three key members of
management walked out
also
in my
mind this comes to the level of
sabotage Gunstock was shut down because
of the walk out of these people and it
threw everybody into a
crisis
and they all had to do something we had
open we know the way that things went
because shortly after this walk out
the man in the corner office said hey
those folks can have a job with the
state of New Hampshire we'll put them in
parks and recreations whatever we got to
do those good people deserve
jobs what he should have been doing is
talking to his attorney
general that didn't
happen that's why we're here and that's
why we need forensic
orders because as you know now
$1,500 was given to the man in the
corner
office in two separate checks over two
different years and this was a mistake
by the CEO because prior
to him writing directly a check to the
campaign of
a gubernatorial
candidate they used a different system
much more popular system it's called
lobbying and
lobbyist and you usually in the past
money was filtered through ski New
Hampshire
perhaps the lobbyist who was here today
sitting next to the former CEO the soon
to be former CEO thank God he's
retiring um those donations were made to
the uh lobbying firm that represents the
ski industry for New Hampshire I'm sure
they don't say where those monies are
going to go anything like that
so that's why we're here I said I'd take
two minutes I'm probably about there so
if you have questions I'd be happy to
Gallagher
um
so in
2022 um the whole Gunstock
issue uh
was a pretty major issue in the
legislative elections that year would do
you think it would be fair to interpret
the results of the 2022 election as a
referendum of Voters opinions on the
Gunstock
[Music]
matter
well I don't know how much you know
about the uh media industry and who
knows in the forensic audit the new Hamp
the Laconia daily Sun's um payments for
advertising might be looked at um um but
there was a uh a campaign which had
started previously in previous October
November with citizens for gun Gunstock
which then morphed into citizens for
bellnap um there was a big lobbying U
push on a lot of money spent and uh
probably in the order of
$50,000 to select certain candidates to
win and replace and naturally I was top
Target because certain people don't like
me because I like the
truth for
questions CA I have one rep uh honorable
Mr
honorable um you mentioned
2022 that Gunstock was shut down did the
did Gunstock end up having a uh a losing
money year did they or if you're not if
you can't answer it that no I I believe
they made money actually um the there
was they the the shutdown happened just
before soulfest which they were trying
to get rid of in in the first place and
of course it's a Summer Event so uh they
they managed to um get rid of The
Unwanted Gunstock Commissioners replace
them with a favorable U body and uh
proceeded on and uh did a fine time as
far as the uh profitability of gun stock
let's always remember that back in 2000
uh they essentially went underwater and
dumped $6 million of debt on to the
county
taxpayers so that was a big hit and
hardly a profit Center thank you very
much further
questions see you then thank you very
much for your
up uh thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee um my name is Doug Lambert
and I'm the current chair of the
Gunstock area commission the five member
board appointed by the bellnap county
delegation with the statutory
responsibility of managing Gunstock
Mountain
Resort the commission stands in
unanimous opposition to the passage of
House Bill 1414 dfn in urges this
committee to issue a recommendation of
inexpedient to
legislate
in a typical situation the basis for
most legislation is that it should be
formed with the intention of fixing a
problem while responding to the needs
and wishes of a majority of the public
being
represented the proposed bill before you
does neither it seeks to fix a problem
that does not exist and is in no way
serving any measurable numbers of the
belnap county citizens this B Bill
contains three components that seeks to
modify the current law that directs the
operation and maintenance of the gun
stock area this was last revised in 2020
and became effective September of that
year in the form of House Bill
1442 since that time it has proven
itself to be a sound piece of
legislation that maintains a just
balance between allowing the area to to
build and maintain self Su
sustainability while providing a payback
to belnap
county in that 2020 legislation it
provided that
1.75% of yearly gross operating income
shall be turned over to the bellnap
County Treasurer within 45 days of the
receipt and approval of the annual
audit in the most recent fiscal cycle
this amounted to just over
$352,000 delivered to belnap County
prior to September 2020 rather than
delivering money to count to the county
Gunstock was borrowing money
underwritten by belnap County to
facilitate the revenue anticipation note
or ran as we was referred to earlier it
is the opinion of the Gunstock area
commission that the current percentage
amounts strikes a fair balance between
providing a monetary benefit to the
citizens and taxpayers of belnap County
while allowing the gun stock area to
cover all expenses and plan for the
ongoing current and future needs while
remaining on the chared cost of
self-sufficiency the first component of
the proposed legislation before you
seeks to change the percent to 3% nearly
double to make a change at this time
when many of the past Financial stresses
and difficulties have been identified
and corrected could begin to remove
important operational and future
investment capital and could start a
process to chip away and put at risk
what has been achieved since
2020 gun Stock's Financial benefit to
belnap county is very significant in the
areas such as local Employment Services
provided by local businesses and
contractors and of course the
substantial tourism draw across the
seasons this requires continued
investment maintenance and an ability to
attract staff in a competitive labor
market to tamper with this valuable
County asset could result in
ramifications far greater than the
actual dollars that might show on the
treasur is ledger
book the second component of this bill
seeks to require the video recording of
all Gunstock area meetings the
commission is already governed by the
relevant laws of the State of New
Hampshire as they pertain to public
bodies all of its business is conducted
in full compliance with the right to
know law RSA
91a currently through policy our
meetings are in fact being recorded and
made available to the public on a
voluntary basis to put such a
requirement into law that goes above and
beyond that which is required of all
other public bodies in the state of New
Hampshire does not seem to be a
necessary step the third component of
this bill which I'd like to speak to is
the mandated uh
Financial uh forensic audit within the
5year
periods this aspect of the bill before
you for
consideration is redundant when one
reads and applies the words of the
existing governing law as modified back
in
2022 quote all Financial transactions of
the commission shall be audited annually
and at such other times and in such
manner as the County Convention May
determine
there is simply no need for the mandated
forensic audit all records and financial
information is available under current
91a law if such evidence is discovered
that could call for further scrutiny
provided by an audit of this nature the
County Convention can examine it and
call for one if they should determine to
do so I would further add uh in to
answer to in answer to a question
earlier approximately 15 years ago the
County Administrator was caught in
bezeling money from belnap County I
attended the trial and watched her
walked away in handcuffs she was
convicted I'm not aware and I could be
mistaken but I don't believe that belnap
County subjects itself to a forensic
audit now you would think that if there
ever was a situation that perhaps might
call for it there was it and I'll
further add that I'm a member of the
commission a five member commission that
is appointed by the county
delegation now at what point are we
going to say that we can't trust any
member of government any person in a
public body I took an oath as did my
fellow Commissioners and when we when
the current commission began operation
we looked deeply we took into
consideration the concerns of the other
reps that spoke here prior and we did a
deep dive we actually conducted a if you
will forensic audit of our own of this
2021 um budget and we spent many hours
going through check by check in and went
down every issue that representative
ktoa had brought to the audit firm in
the course of their traditional audit
now
I I guess um perhaps if if we're not
going to trust the Gunstar commission
who are duly appointed where members of
the government here in the state of New
Hampshire if we can't trust us and we
can't trust the county delegation that
oversees us and have to put into law
some additional
requirements where do we stop do we stop
there do we go to the general court the
Senate where does it end um the this
entire bill just again I'll close and
say that it it seeks to fix a problem
that does not exist and it seeks to add
extraordinary costs above and beyond
what we've already been doing and by the
way it rained for the entire week of
Christmas we lost the Saturday of Martin
Luther King weekend uh Revenue thus far
this year is almost a million dollars
behind last year we are very weather
driven and we can go from one year to
the next from having a very successful
year to having a very difficult year and
the monies that we may save in our
profits will help to carry us through so
that we don't have to come back to
bellnap County taxpayers ever again and
ask them to foot the bill it's a much
better um experience to go there once a
year and hand over a nice check but we
don't want to jeopardize all that has
been achieved in the last four years and
I thank you for your time and I'm happy
to answer
questions thank you for your testimony
any
questions seeing none thank you very
much we'll call we've got two more pink
cards up here I'll say the names just in
case anybody else was thinking of
speaking uh Tom day you're up next and
good afternoon thank you for listening
to my testimony my name is Tom day I'm
the president and general manager of
Gunstock Mountain Resort um I've been in
the ski industry for 40 years and I've
been at Gunstock for four the ski
business is totally weather related and
the operating costs are based on that
we're constantly adjusting operating
plans to to basically deal with the
weather problems that we have we're in
business for 13 weeks really we have 13
weeks to make money and as uh uh
commissioner Lambert mentioned during
this past um Christmas week we it rained
pretty much every day and uh we did end
up without with the Martin Luther King
hit we ended up a million dollars behind
what our normal budgeted revenues were
so it's it's just it's it's and that's
unrecoverable you can't add you can't
add 10 more days to a month you can't
add another holiday you're just you're
when it's gone by it's gone
by the Gunstock commission as we've
talked about quite a bit so I won't go
go too much into it pays 1.7 the Gunstar
pays 1.75 of gross revenue to the
Commission in the past three years we've
paid over $675,000 on that thing to that
um the the but the positive the positive
impact of Gunstock in the community is
is is is important and we've heard a lot
about how well G Gunstock does and what
it does I think once again it's
important to recognize that since 2020
we have not borrowed a revenue
anticipation note and and that's I took
over in 2020 and I couldn't figure out
why we needed to borrow a million
dollars to keep our business running so
in 2019 our Revenue was $12 million and
in 2023 our Revenue was $20 million
we've spent we've um in four years we've
done $12 million worth of improvements
to the resort and didn't borrow a dime
just last summer alone we did $6 million
of of improvements the the thought of
even having to go to ask for Revenue
anticipation note is is not is alien to
me but we can get into that situation if
we're if we have a bad window like this
but we don't want to have to do that
again um the forensic audits you've
heard about it um that you've heard
about the numbers and the cost of the
forensic audit um I'm not that familiar
with it I can tell you that I know
forensic audits basically look at every
check and we' we generate between 3,000
and 4,000 checks in a in a year so um
that would be a fairly expensive process
and and I know there's been a lot of
discussion about um about that uh prior
to to this hearing today and we are very
successful I think something else is
important to recognize too is we have
$5.2 Million worth of payroll 62% of
those people live in bellnap County um
we are a main driver for the revenue in
in the town and if we don't have a good
season um they don't have a good season
either and and I've talked to plenty of
the local businesses and they're they're
suffering just like we're suffering this
year so um I'd like to correct a couple
of things things too is that the
contribution was $1,500 not $5,000 that
was that made to to the 2020 and 2022
see so I I think that's really all that
I have to say Doug did mention that
there was a there way before my time
there was a default on I thought it was
in 2010 but apparently it might have
been
20 2000 um you know there has been no
default since we've been involved it's
been nothing but an upo trajectory we've
really tried to improve the experience
of the guests there and try to create a
better environment for a gem of an area
that is Gunstock Mountain Resort and I'm
proud to have been involved in it for
the past four years um and um if there's
any questions um please feel free to ask
me I appreciate your
time representative K Hill thank you Mr
CH thank you for taking my question and
thank you for giving your testimony here
you said you guys are open for 13 weeks
but I heard mention of a soulfest um do
you do you guys make Revenue in other
ways other than the ski season 85% of
your Revenue comes in the ski season 15%
of your Revenue comes in the summer
months quick followup go ahead are you
still doing soulfest and things like
that like to J no we uh contrary to the
way that it was stated prior to
testimony with me we are not doing Soul
f because soulfest uh did not make money
in fact it cost it cost us
money and we didn't when I got there I
didn't know that because the the year I
got there um I co hit so we didn't have
it that summer we watched it the
following year and realized it did not
make us
money representative y
Kella thank you uh thank you for taking
the
question um it
seem from your
testimony uh that there was um multiple
I think on the order of five to 6,000 or
million dollars of improvements in the
current or the prior
year um and additional improvements in
the year before um can you speak a
little bit to why you believe that
$300,000 would of of additional Revenue
getting transferred to bellnap would um
essentially threaten the existence of of
that in relation to these massive
improvements that which are you're able
to do based on the revenue yeah because
we as as you can see from this year our
revenues on our constant we've been with
this the weather has been with us and
constantly it's been well but we're
going to be under the weather this year
with that stuff so that's something that
that we think is going to be could be a
problem for us going down the road is it
going to be if we do better does it go
up another 175 1.75% so we just feel
that it's from what we have for
problem representative Elwood thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for being here
today does Gunstock have a long range
plan um contingency plan based on bad
weather in the future well we do we do
have um with cash cash cash positive so
we can handle having you know a a Bad
season so that we don't have to go back
and borrow a revenue anticipation note
or we don't have to worry about having
to do do anything with the county so we
do have we are cash positive that we can
handle bad
Seasons follow up Mr chairman thank you
I'm talking more about um converting to
a summer Resort type of
activity you know
destination um if we run out of s what
what happens to gun actually
representative that's not really
pertains to this bill so I'm going to
ask that you avoid answering that
question are there any further
questions see none I have I have just
one sir um you mentioned $5.2 million
annual payroll 60% of that is belnap
County um of that 5.2 million how what
percentage of that is full-time yearound
employment 80 80 people is of the in the
summer in the winter we have 700
employees part-time but but 80 of that
is full-time year round benefited
insured uh so was 80 full-time year
around and how many you said in the
winter in the winter we go up to as high
as
700 thank you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony I have one more pink card as I
flarity
well good afternoon thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee my
name is Brendan flarey and I'm here
today on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association of counties uh the counties
are opposed to House Bill
1414 um the bill unnecessarily uh eats
into the mountains profits
and
uh it that that inflicts unnecessary
harm on the resort uh it's the county
County's position excuse me that um the
remaining profits that aren't sent to
belnap County should be reinvested into
the resort um in order to keep that
asset
around that's all I got so thank you
that's it yeah very good I like it
representative
y
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
did you were you're representing the
counties did any other counties like did
Rockingham County actually uh weigh in
on I'm gonna have to take I'm gonna have
to take that back to the county
administrators for followup because I
don't know the answer to that okay thank
much
represent I don't know if you have the
answer this question but I was hearing
we heard testimony about A6 billion doll
debt that got passed on to bop County do
we know if that debt was paid I don't
know I don't have the answer to that so
I'll have the county administrators
follow
up okay seeing no more
questions
comments okay right with that that was
the last P
oh need to get that up here sooner
Senator Sor I introduce a build so all
right we're
all on the thank you for your testimony
of
course all right now we have the last
pink last speak and I'll be super brief
Lang so I'm Senator Tim Lang uh I am I
serve Senate District 2 which is the
Lakes Region uh North and um I before
being a senator I was a three-term state
representative on the bellnap county
delegation um just to put this in
perspective a little bit I I oppose the
bill and the reason I oppose the bill is
because we've just recently changed this
law this law was put into effect in 1959
and we changed it two years ago to
increase the percentage um it used to be
that the County Commissioners gave us I
think it was about $175,000 a year the
law was changed that number went up as
you heard heard lastly was
$352,000 the same point when I was on a
county delegation we were encouraging
the county the Gunstock area
Commissioners to start creating cash
reserves to weather bad weather no pun
intended um but to to deal with
shortcomings in Revenue
and to deal with not having to request
the revenue anticipation note which does
put taxpayers on the hook um if they
should fail I think Senator you uh
representative you had a question about
whether the debt was paid off yes the
debt was paid off um so uh I oppose it
because again we've just recently made a
change this law we need to have the law
in place for a while to a to give the C
the gun stack a Commissioners time to
develop the cash reserves and understand
we're not it's not going to constantly
move in the gold posts on them while do
this I think it's also in section two
with the 91a addition requirement would
is seems outrageous consider we they're
already governed by 91a and like every
other board in the state and the last
part that last piece about the friends
of audit the county delegation who
maintains the uh the oversight of this
already has the right to ask for an
audit so again I think it's an unneeded
piece of Law and I just encourage you to
vote
itl representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman thank you Senator one quick
question you talked about the cash
reserves do you know what that is
they've talked about a lot of Capital
Improvements which we know areas like
that have to do but what types of things
would you have for cash reers or the
amount thank you again I I won't answer
I don't know their forensic their
accounting sides unless um their their
accountant Was Here let them answer it
but I don't know the answer I do know
that we've given them we've asked them
to put cash reserves aside so that um
they in the in the event of a Bad season
we're not going for a ren anticipation
note not knowing what the next season's
going to look like and potentially
putting taxpayers on the hooks we've
asked them to start creating savings
account like any good business does to
deal with potential downturns in the
market and be able to maintain through
that thank
you seeing no more questions thank you
for your testimony repes uh
Senator okay I have no more pink cards
uh on the blue sheet we had one sign in
in favor and I show three
against and with that we will close a
1414 and as soon as the clerk is ready
one
okay with that we are going to go ahead
and open up the next and final hearing
of the day HP 1362 relative to
authorizing municipalities to stabilize
rent increases in rental housing
representative Reed you have the floor
thank you so much Mr chair and thank you
honorable members for the record my name
is Ellen Reed I represent Rockingham 10
which is New Market and new Fields um
and I will say and this is completely on
me uh that I uh had a scheduling Kur
fuffle where I put the hearing date
correct but not the month in my calendar
for this hearing and whilst I am clearly
here I I called off a work uh
unfortunately the person who is the
housing law expert of the state who
wrote this bill could not come in last
minute because he was counting on me to
to give him the heads up so um if the
the chair is gracious enough to consider
uh having me introduce and continuing so
that the expert can speak to you all his
name is Elliot Barry um I would be great
very grateful but of course it is your
discretion and I will happily introduce
this so um you know housing is our top
crisis in this state New Hampshire
Business Review uh just ranked us um the
second worst state for Millennials
primarily because of the housing
situation of course you know the graying
of New Hampshire is something that we
have all heard repeatedly but the
graying of New Hampshire is one and the
same with the housing crisis the reason
the only reason really the predominant
reason certainly that we can't attract
and keep young people is because they
can't buy a home here and they can't
even find affordable housing um New
Hampshire is rated the fourth worst
state in the country uh for
housing 75% of New Hampshire citizens
consider the housing crisis very
serious um if you are making so we talk
about minimum wage a lot as you know
it's 725 in the state forget 725 if
you're making double that at $15 an hour
it would take you three weeks to pay for
an average apartment so the the rule of
thumb is it should be about one week
about 25 30% of your income should go to
housing but it would take you 75% of
your income to afford a home now if you
consider somebody may be working at
minimum wage um it would take them 100%
of their income if they are working 62
hours a week and they don't pay taxes
somehow which of course they would um I
didn't care to calculate the taxes on
that last year 94 homeless individuals
died in this state uh for context the
third cause a leading cause of death in
this state is car accidents which took
127 so not that much more um so it it is
a very very serious um crisis and I I
really want you all to try to hold on to
that as we go through this bill and and
the details of the bill so the bill
before you is enabling only and the New
Hampshire Municipal Association is in
favor of this bill um I understand that
that lobbyist is currently in a meeting
but intends to come here and testify I
think usually he gets called last um and
I want to talk about what this bill
covers so it's rent stabilization uh it
does not cover non-restricted uh units
it does not cover manufactured housing
it doesn't cover adus or federally
subsidized housing and it doesn't cover
housing less than 15 years old if it's
built after um the if a town enables uh
the rent stabilization so I just want
you to realize it's only your basic
restricted housing
um and the reason this enabling is
needed is because these towns are in an
emergency situation to provide housing
they have to do something this would be
an emergency measure that a town would
uh Implement and they would implement it
only as an emergency because their
inherent um motive is to keep values
high and if they Implement something
like this they do run the potential risk
of suppressing values in their town but
as we know right now it's quite the
opposite and towns also have the need to
provide Workforce housing in their town
so this is a tool if they so choose to
use it to help balance those Market
forces because in the current
situation um essentially what we have
and I I've testified to this fact in the
in the past is a def facto price fixing
situation because you don't have a free
market when you have a situation where
people are forced to buy something like
with housing you have no choice so with
free market the idea is that the supply
side and the demand side are both free
to interact and walk away if necessary
but when you're forcing someone to buy
something because they have no choice in
order to live you are tying the hands of
one side of that equation and when
you're doing that it's no longer a free
market and what that means is that
landlords have no reason to compete with
each other they all benefit from all
raising the prices because you're going
to pay it
anyway
so what this does and I want to be clear
this is rent stabilization so it limit
it allows towns to limit the rental
increases on units in their town but not
below 5% first of all so I know that
last year there we I had a bill that
enabled a number of things among them
would be what you would call rent
control what that is is allowing a town
to say a certain number like you can't
rent this unit for more than $800 that's
not what this says what this says you
may be renting it for $4,000 right now
and the town would be able to say okay
you can't raise it more than 5% next
year and that's the worst like that's
the lowest they would be able to to
restrict that um it also very
importantly and and and I I want you to
pay attention to this allows for a fair
return on investment for landlords so if
that 5% or whatever level a town
restricts the increase at is not enough
for the landlord to recruit reasonable
and necessary costs and specifically
this will be paragraph three on the
second page so that includes property
taxes owner paid utilities maintenance
and repairs and other reasonable and
necessary operating costs if a
owner has those increases the owner
would be exempt from that that
restricted
amount it also for any town that
implements a rent stabilization
ordinance um would have that town
establish a board uh to exempt such
landlords so they'd have to have a board
to hear the landlords and and and have
that evidence brought to them um it also
enables towns to have uh or require 100
days note 12 days notice of rent
increases or the removal of the property
from the market right now very
frequently people are experiencing
30day effectively the the bare minimum
is 30-day notice and so if there's like
a change in ownership or whatever the
next thing they know is there's a huge
increase in in rent and they're
basically out on their ear and they had
have a month or less to to
adjust every ordinance that is adopted
pursuant to this RSA would expire
automatically in five
years and uh I also would welcome any
landlords that might be in opposition to
um discuss potential compromise with me
um but we have to do something to
address it I think it's very very very
clear that doing what we've been doing
is leading to dire consequences in this
state it's leading to the fact that
people cannot live in this state and so
I don't think especially in a bill that
protects landlord profit protects their
reasonable return on investment and
deals with that crisis I don't think
that saying that that's like not fair
isn't is is reasonable I'm happy to um
engage with the interested parties and
see what what wording works for people
but we have to do something and with
that um I basically covered my main
points and I'm happy to answer any
questions
testimony representative
Brown thank you for indulging me Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so on uh line 19 of the bill it
talks about minimum constitutionally
protected standards can you explain that
to me or elaborate on it for me thank
you line 19 of the first page
yes we're defining Fair return on
investment and as I understand it and
again this is why I've asked and I'm I
feel so disrespectful not being able to
see you across the speaker um it's why
I've asked for a continuance to allow um
the like I said an ex the leading expert
who's actually taken this very issue to
the Supreme Court in New Hampshire so he
very intimately understands what the
constitutionality is of making sure that
landlords are um my understanding from
him is that landlords and other business
owners have a con constitutionally
protected um right to have a fair return
on their investment um from government
so like government can't impede upon you
from having a fair return on on
investment and so that is why he is
included that and um but he would be
able to speak more as an expert to that
thanks representative majority thank you
Mr chairman I'll be very quick thank you
for taking my question in Roman 2 the
first sentence says the governing body
created an ordinance the second sentence
says ordinance or regulation a
nitpicking but an ordinance is binding a
regulation is more like a policy what
what what would your preference be that
it be an ordinance or that it can be as
I'm going to say loose but I hope you
understand that word as a regulation not
being the expert and lawyer that wrote
you representative
FR thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um you define this as
the ability of a town to act in an
emergency situation if I understood you
correctly as we currently are I'm sorry
and uh how how are you how are you
defining an Emer
situation and on a Town level who would
make that determination and what would
the criteria
be the determination for what an
emergency situation is so it would be
for example
um Perhaps it is as broad as not being
able to meet Workforce housing which is
required of them um legally but it may
be as narrow as deaths from homelessness
like I just said so um yeah we're we're
in a crisis the crisis may vary town to
town which is why this enabling
legislation which does nothing on its
own is good but um the who would
determine that would be the same bodies
that would put the ordinance in so that
would be your select board or your Town
Council city
council representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair um can you
tell me who is this expert oh Elliot
Barry I I did I thought I mentioned his
name I'm sorry if I didn't he's the
former direct recently retired director
of in HLA thank you Mr chair can I have
a quick followup go
ahead thank you and the the lines that
uh others have mentioned on page one the
18 and 19 talking about the
constitutionally protected
standards what are the proofs that
somebody has to Pro give to prove that
um you know their the their return on
investment fits this so it would be the
co the cost that I including the costs
that I read uh from paragraph three on
the second page um so
essentially presuming right now that
landlords are setting the rent at a rate
that gives them you know being free of
any other restrictions landlords are
setting the rate at what they want so
right now we're presuming in the current
situ ation they're getting a fair return
on investment now something could happen
the roof could collapse they might need
to repair something the property taxes
could go up the utilities that they pay
could go up whatever could happen and
they come in with those
you representative got three got three
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony how would this bill help
the crisis of the the housing crisis
which is a issue of not enough
housing so so the housing crisis is
ultimately an issue of not affordable
housing and one of those major factors
that is contributing to that is not
enough housing so because we have a lack
of and I should say we have a lack of
units on the market we don't have an
actual lack of actual roofs we actually
have I believe the number I last looked
up and this is maybe 2 years old 72
empty homes for every homeless person
not family person in this state so we
don't actually have a lack of roofs or a
lack of houses most of those are
vacation homes that are sitting empty
and they're not on the market we do have
about 60,000 I think units uh too few on
the market and that is in part what's
contributing to that increase um that is
causing it to be unaffordable especially
for the young families that the the
state really wants to attract so that's
first of all that's the the actual
crisis how this helps is that what right
now we're seeing an exponential boom in
the rental levels uh my town alone last
year experienced um it was one
particular owner who came in and bought
about 60% of all of the uh multif family
units in the town uh he recently listed
them as a package for sale but uh he
upon taking ownership increased the rent
for those units for people who were not
yet out of their or who were out of
their lease and were going month-to
Monon
250% So within one month people who were
paying $700 $800 were now having to pay
like something like
$2,700 and obviously that's just not
affordable these were the people who
worked as post three postal workers
actually were impacted for our town um
people who worked at our local
restaurants um these people were driven
out most of them left they were driven
out of our town so that is what the
housing crisis looks like and what this
does and let me be extremely clear this
does not reduce the rental level
currently set right now what this does
is simply allow towns to prevent the
continuance of this ridiculous 200 300%
rental increases quick followup Mr
chairman quickly just a quick question
is that proper you were talking mode
empty um no I don't think that they're
empty they they've attracted people who
don't work in our town are not the
postal workers are not the sandwich
makers are not the people who work at
the gas station the the retired veterans
they've attracted people I think largely
from
Massachusetts um who work from home and
get paid quite
well representative savus thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question first of all I apologize
because maybe I'm not reading correctly
versus what I heard you say um so point
out where I'm wrong please um you said
that adus were exempt from this yes ad
well
specifically ACC accessory structure
unit as defined in
67471 I guess we could bring up
67471 um but tell me in the bill where
the exemption language is oh page two uh
number five that's line also happens to
be line five all the exemptions start on
page one uh starting with
20 up 29 covered property which is
covered by this section means all
residential rental structures accept and
then there's a numbered list thank
you further questions representative
gallager um so kind of to follow up on
representative guth's question and um so
yeah it's often said that um rent
control or rent stabilization will have
a negative impact on Supply but um we've
also got other bills in the work that
are more meant to um address the supply
side of things so if those both pass um
do you think that would be enough to um
cover it and um would you
um would would you maybe be open to
combining um rent control stabilization
legislation with some of the more Pro
Supply things in the
future thank you for the question and I
I was very brief when I mentioned the
exemption but th this specifically does
not cover things that are built after a
rent stabiliz and it is stabilization
it's not rent control that was last year
uh this specifically exempts new
structures that are built after a rent
stabilization ordinances passed for 15
years so it does not have a cooling
effect on building having said that
towns are kind of stuck because they
have to supply Workforce housing and
they are famously as you all know
against anything like the measures we've
seen that increase density so how do you
this if you don't want to loosen up uh
zoning ordinances to allow for more
density but you have to meet Workforce
housing this allows them to start doing
that again it doesn't reduce any rents
but it prevents this in increasing
expansion of rental uh amounts that
we're experiencing and it allows them to
do that without cooling new building
structures so or new building of new
structures for 15
years
oh oops I didn't realize my yeah
thanks representative
lales thank you for taking my
question so this is enabling legislation
correct so we could have two towns
sitting right beside each other one
adopts the law the other does not a
developer comes in and he's wanting to
locate some apartment house houses which
one is he going to
choose so this is a factor that a Town
Council or select board would have to
take into consideration before passing
this but my point is that it's
Laboratories of democracy every town has
to decide what's right for them this is
enabling only it doesn't do anything on
its own if this is going to impact
negatively negatively impact that town
then the select board or Town Council
would likely not pass it but if they
weigh everything and go the the benefits
outweigh the the cost the negatives the
potential scaring off somebody who again
they would be exempt for 15 years anyway
but let's say they're worried about
building because in the 16th year they
wouldn't be able to continue increasing
potentially continue increasing then
that's something that Town Council has
to to weigh and if they decide that
that's too costly for them then they
won't do it but again every single
ordinance passed pursuant to this
years seeing no more questions thank you
for your testimony thank you so
Klein uh thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee for this opportunity to
speak uh my name is Drew Klein I'm
president of the Josiah Bartlett Center
for Public Policy which is New
Hampshire's free market Think Tank um
and I would say that we we're here in
response to this bill really to just
issue a warning uh based on the effects
of what will inevitably happen if this
bill passes the language in the bill uh
is allowable rent increase um You can
call it stabilization all you want but
that is a that is a price cap and that
is rent control and there is there's
really only a handful of
issues um that really bringing together
economists of the left and the right
right and rent control is one of them
there's almost Universal agreement of
the devastating effect that rent control
has um it universally is recognized as
reducing both the quality and the
housing and to show you how
ideologically broad this consensus is I
one of my favorite probably my
favorite Paul Krugman colum The leftwing
Economist in the New York Times uh was
one he wrote in
2000 where he was responding to a story
The New York Times had on the really
dire situation that San Francisco was
dealing with in housing where San
Francisco renters the New York Times
headline called them supplicants to the
landlords that's how bad the problem had
gotten where landlords were requiring
renters
to dress nice interview show them all
kinds of resumes not not just dealing
with an economic issue here but the
landlords had such power over the
renters and Krugman wrote that he could
tell just by reading the story even
though it didn't mention rent
control that San Francisco had a rent
control policy and sure enough he looked
it up and found that San Francisco had a
rent control policy and he wrote that
that's what happens when you have rent
control and just a quote from his column
uh the analysis of rent control is among
the best understood in all of economics
and among economists any uh among
economists any way and one of the least
controversial almost every freshman
level textbook contains a case study on
rent control using its known adverse
side effects to illustrate the
principles of supply and demand as from
Paul
Krugman just to give you a just a really
quick example of some of the recent
research on rent control St Paul
Minnesota passed a rent control
ordinance in 2021 a University of
Southern California study in
2022 found that rent control cause
property values to Fall by
66 to 7% That's a $1.6 billion loss in
property value in a
year a 2018 study of rent control back
to San Francisco found that it reduced
the supply of rent and housing by
15% and raised rents by
5% well how did it raise rents by 5%
well not every unit is controlled by the
rent Control Ordinance as would be the
case here when you limit when you put a
price cap on some units you will
inevitably raise the rent of the other
units everyone is going to be worse off
Cambridge Massachusetts famously had
rent control for 24
years when that policy was lifted in
afterwards lifting rent control in
Cambridge Mass more than doubled the
direct dollar investments in new
Mass that is astonishing I won't read
the rest here I've submitted this
written testimony what happens when you
have rent control even if you do it in
the way this bill does which is try to
limit it try to keep the ordinance short
try to exempt new apartments inevitably
what happens
is you reduce the value of rental
properties you reduce the value of all
rental properties not just the ones that
are covered by this ordinance this
ordinance uh you would enable
municipalities to have a 5-year
ordinance that would have to expire
after five years okay so let's say some
investor takes a a
risk
and decides erroneously to build an rent
control town after the ordinance kicks
into effect instead of the town next
door that doesn't have
one what happens when that ordinance
expires in 5 years he's got anart
building there the new rent Control
Ordinance kicks in um I think and you
would have to ask the sponsor I could be
wrong but it would assume that that new
building would then be covered by the
rent Control
Ordinance New Hampshire does have a
massive problem with rental with a
shortage of rental housing we all know
this I agree with the bill sponsor on
that the reason you can look this up we
did in state is is available through
State data the building permits tell the
story in 2013 New Hampshire's apartment
vacancy rate was
3.4% that's just 10 years
ago last year it's
0.6% go look up the building permits you
will see a sharp decline in the number
of building permits issued this is not a
free market problem we have a shortage
of rental housing because local
governments have made it illegal to
build rental housing J High Bartlett
Center published a study in 2021
demonstrating that our housing problem
in New Hampshire is a shortage created
by local government ordinances you will
make that problem
worse with this bill you will that if
this bill passes our vacancy rate will
go down not
up that's just the inevitable math that
will follow so as as good as this sounds
the answer to our shortage of housing is
not to create a bigger shortage it's to
get government out of the way to allow
more units to be constructed we have to
solve that building permit problem
that's the problem we face with that I'm
happy to take questions thank you for
your testimony representative
gallager um so a lot of the
um case studies you mentioned were about
rent control
specifically um but uh this bill uh
takes great pains to be about
stabilization instead um so I was
wondering um if you
had if you could use examples instead
that were of rent stabilization
specifically instead of rent control I
think I think rent stabilization is a
term of art not a um economic term it's
a price cap which is a rent control it's
all rent
control further
questions representative Gilman thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question sure um in talking about the uh
how the ordinances are holding back rent
rentable units is that um how would that
be solved would it be Sol because well
how would that
be I wish I had the easy answer to that
representative that is the tricky
question um look the the easy the short
answer is local governments have to
relax their ordinances and allow more
density and allow more units to be built
that's the simple answer I mean it's
it's not simple in practice but that
that's the problem we're facing I gave a
little leeway on that one that was
actually not part of our bill
representative but I allowed the
testimony to go forward representative
Gallagher um so kind of a similar
question to the one I asked to
representative Reed um so you mentioned
um you mentioned that the solution here
is to um
is to get permitting out of the way do
zonning reforms to make it easier to
build more um not rent control or grent
stabilization okay but what if we did
both like would would you consider say a
compromise package where we do both
zoning reform and rent control to be um
acceptable anytime you put rent control
in in any form you will get fewer
apartments and and and less construction
than you would otherwise get so I don't
why you would um allow more construction
and then put a policy in that would
possible further
questions I have one okay is it fair to
say that rent control by Any Other Name
Is Still rent control yeah um and I I
guess I would end on a quote from my my
all-time favorite economics quote is by
a Swedish Economist um who I think put
it really well he is is um his name is
assar lindbeck and reviewing the
literature on rent control he said in
many cases rent control appears to me
the most efficient technique presently
known to destroy a city except for
bombing thank you for that so you no
further questions thank you for your
testimony uh next up we have uh I think
the last name is bacon Matt
Realtors
thank you all for allowing me the time
testimony today uh my name is Matt bacon
I'm a senior adviser at anagnos realy
and development in Manchester uh one of
the largest developers of affordable and
sustainable housing communities in our
state um however I'm here on behalf of
my Association I'm a member of the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors the
public policy committee at the state
level as well as the commercial
investment board of realtors public
policy committee and the past president
of the commercial investment board of
realtors last year um I'm here
representing NH and itself 7,000 members
Realtors are opposed to HB 1362 and we
urge that you vote at itl um could could
please
one
second
here
sorry for the interruption you may
continue all right uh I'd first like to
address a flawed statement made by the
bill sponsor um that we don't have a
shortage respectfully um per the New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority's
annual report for 2023 it said the state
2023 Statewide housing needs assessment
was published this year and included
some Stark numbers
23670 housing units are needed now to
stabilize our housing market it also
noted that by 2040 we will need nearly
990,000 more units than we have today I
would like to agree with the previous
gentleman that right now we have a
building permit and Supply constraint um
and our uh internal Think Tank New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority that
is charged with Gathering the data and
supporting that in support of
Distributing federal funds uh clearly
agrees 100% with that assessment um
stabilization uh is merely a semantic
disguise uh to cloak what this really is
and that this is rent control this bill
eliminates a landlord's ability to set
their own rents instead the rents would
be entirely under the purview of a local
government body to determine what is and
is not a fair return on investment to
yield a fair return if a municipality
opted to undertake this
um ordinance in New Hampshire the
determination of what is an acceptable
rate of return for rental has always
been in the hands of the property owner
and the general free market forces to
determine not the government under 1362
the government would take control of
deciding how much money a property owner
is allowed to make I grew up in the live
fre or die State and I want to stay in
one that's governed fairly and opposed
to overregulation what happens if a
property owner decides to make
significant Renovations or improvements
to a building new bathrooms new kitchens
HVAC roof or improving other amenities
on the property that might um be
beneficial for the lifestyle or for the
safety of the property uh or as I
testified regarding previous year's
legislation if taxes and insurance
drastically inrease on the property will
the property owner have to run each and
every item by this government entity to
seek rent approvals prior to this to
raise them to cover these costs or do
they try to app earn the approval only
after the construction is completed or
do they simply not make the Improv ments
which is happening in New York and San
Francisco where rent stabilization has
been enacted and let structures fall
into disrepair or do they follow the
state of provision and remove them from
the rental market further reducing the
supply that we're already finding to be
very
problematic so what if there are cost
overruns unforeseen circumstances or
increases in construction costs while
this is going on uh will the property
owner have to treat this new government
entity as a sort of construction manager
waiting for approval on materials and
labor cost before moving forward forward
to complete necessary repairs for
habitability and the bill seems to
require that a property with a $5,000 a
month rent be treated the same as those
with $1,000 a month affordable rent
we're not sure why those in the highest
price units would need the same type of
protection extended to them or is the
intent that the municipalities can pick
and choose which types of units they
would control under these ordinances
that seems problematic and open to many
legal disasters that could create cost
increases that trickle down and the
battles that come from from them also
this could enable towns to become even
less friendly to investment growth and
free market stabilization as pointed out
by the previous uh gentleman ultimately
this would make an already tight rental
market worse excuse me it will clearly
disincentivize those who want to
construct multif family housing due to
the Future uncertainty and the less
total housing units that's something
we've been fighting to avoid in support
of housing affordability and
availability Realtors understand the
well-intentioned impulse behind this
bill however the better answer to the
problem of scarce housing housing and
increasing rents is to increase the
housing Supply rather than control
prices which discourages investment in
housing and I'll wrap up with mentioning
that with more units on the market the
rents will stabilize it's always what
happens when demand meets Supply in
order to expand housing we need to
expand property rights in New Hampshire
overregulation to legislate plenty of
other governments have made mistakes in
this area that we can learn from so
let's not make the mistakes that we
could learn from elsewhere thank you
thank you for your testimony do we have
questions representative Gallagher so
yeah same question as I asked to the
previous two testifiers um so you
mentioned um we should be doing these
supply side things like permitting
reform and Zoning reform um would
wouldn't it be possible to reduce the
costs of of perating and Zoning enough
so that
um that it's actually less than the
amount that's
being or I I mean more than the amount
that's being kept so it ends up being a
net positive
anyways uh I don't have the math right
sorry we we're not going to answer that
question we try to keep our questions
specifically to the bill and that has
gone off off offside the bill do we have
other further
questions represent
FR thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um would you agree or
disagree with the hypothesis that one of
the limiting factors to
increasing housing Supply in this state
is the availability or lack there of of
infrastructure specifically water and
sewer and for the carrying capacity of
land that is not on Municipal
infrastructure and if the answer to the
question is yes can you estimate um what
percentage or okay we're going to stop
the question on that that's also totally
unrelated to rent uh
stabilization are there any questions
about the bill I mean these are all
great questions don't get me wrong but
they're not specific to what we're
talking about here F questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
Scher I was going to say good morning
but it's definitely
afternoon apologize I had the flu laugh
world I'm losing my voice um I'll make
this quick because the previous speakers
have really covered a lot of the
important um bits my name is Chris I am
a principal at Elm grve companies we're
a we're a developer and property
management firm here in New Hampshire we
own and manage approximately 1600
Apartments um including um a well
approximately 600 of those are
low-income housing tax credit um
Workforce housing um projects matter of
fact we just finished one in Salem last
week um to I've done a lot of lease UPS
in my day after doing uh building a new
development project and we typically
take about 6 months to fill up a
building we started taking applications
in December and um as of our ribbon
cutting we're 100% pre-leased And we
expect everybody to be moved in by the
end of February um so that puts a point
to the fact that we we do indeed have a
a serious housing crisis and uh demand
is very very high um however uh HP 1362
I don't believe is the answer and we've
all heard you know the the quote about
pornography I I can't Define it but I
know what it is when I see it uh HB 1362
is is indeed rank control rent control
has never succeeded in solving housing
affordability wherever it isn't enacted
it fails and it creates its own set of
un unintended consequences it makes
housing affordability worse not better
the current housing affordability crisis
is a man-made problem with its roots in
local zoning and nimi opposition the
problem has been growing for many years
and even decades study after study shows
us that restri Ive zoning is the culprit
and all of the leading thinkers on this
today would agree the passage of 1362
would cause developers like myself of
multif family housing to avoid those
municipalities where rent controls are
enacted further exacerbating the problem
of supply and affordability these
ordinance could be used by
municipalities and NIMBY Town planners
to further restrict development their
communities simply by enacting the
ordinances which are unfavorable to
development of housing I personally we
would not do business in a community
where we we didn't have the some sense
of certainty and Security in knowing um
how we could project
our our excuse me our budgets you know
10 years out for
example large rent excuse me large rent
increases over the past few years were
caused by tightening Supply exacerbated
by covid-19 and rising cost to Property
Owners we have experienced 40% increases
in taxes 30% increases in insurance and
utility costs and similar increases in
the cost of labor materials during this
period as a member of Governor uh
Governor senuna housing stability
Council I have have the opportunity to
work with stakeholders from across New
Hampshire and can testify that there are
good and effective Solutions being
discussed and implemented here in New
Hampshire that all stakeholders agree
are the right Solutions these include
municipalities adopting less restrictive
zoning ordinances light density and adus
by right fund fing for the development
of Workforce housing and and educational
programs aimed at dispelling common
myths about the impacts of development
on schools crime and
infrastructure would be helpful I urge
you to vote um no on this bill please
thank you for your testimony any
stabilization seeing none thank you for
uh for your testimony I have one more
thank you also more pink card I don't
know if anybody else intends to speak
Sherman thank you Mr chair members of
the committee my name's Phil Sherman my
wife and I own 10 rental units
condominiums in Lebanon I speak in
respectful opposition to this bill we
provide housing for a grand total of 14
people but they like their house the
income from our rental properties
provides a fair amount of our retirement
income a minimum yearly rate increase of
5% plus inflation actually
exceeds the average our average
year-to-year rate increase over the 34
years as we've picked up units along the
way however what could go wrong we
frequently have tenants that are medical
residents they come to Dartmouth
Hitchcock for three or four years of
indentured servitude making a median
salary of about $62,000 a year most of
the time we hold their rent flat for the
time they're tenants so for three or
four years we just leave it alone then
we raise it for the next tenant it bumps
having the government decide what is a
fair return on investment Miss is
reality rents for many of those 34 years
were essentially
flat we beat inflation by about a
percent and a half if you look at it
over the over the long
term I'm neither an economist or even an
expert on housing but as I understand it
the Federal Reserve all transactions
house price index is an interesting read
as there's some correlation between
rents and housing prices they use 1980
as 100 on their scale New England
overall is at 940 right now
Massachusetts is at 1180 New Hampshire
is at 806 but there's more New Hampshire
actually declined for several years
after the 2008 recession then it went up
steeply think of it as a hockey
stick this bill proposes to tell the
investor that whatever the rate of
return was last year is deemed a fair
return on investment if I read it
properly our rents went up a lot in 2022
some didn't increase at all in 2023 as
the economy tightened and they won't
rise much this year except for tenants
that change but the bill seems to assume
that everything happens the same way
every year also some of our units are
approaching 34 and 35 years old while
they're fully Ser serviceable they'll
need major kitchen and possibly bathroom
upgrades in the next few years the only
only reason this will be done is if we
can get a payback in a fairly short
number of
years the bill proposes to treat this
payback as though a large expense to
renovate a kitchen is just another
yearly cost Capp by the government's
view of what's
fair lastly and this was alluded to by
others while the idea of rent control
keeps bubbling up our friends in
Massachusetts realized the Folly of this
approach some 30 years ago and repealed
their rent control law in 2020 three
years ago 60% of the California voters
rejected an expansion of their rent
control I sympathize for our son and
daughter-in-law who live there
thank you I'm happy to answer any
questions my cell phone number is on the
red uh card there if anybody would like
to call
later thank you for your testimony
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony I don't have any uh I do have
Grace just briefly Mr chair n Grace for
the municipal Association uh we do
support uh the concept we uh there was a
case back in the 1970s where Allenstown
attempted to implement uh rent control
that ended up going to the Supreme Court
which decided that they did not have the
authority to do so we obviously support
any effort to increase uh local control
and local Authority I'm happy to take
any questions the committee may
have representative gager um so to
clarify you see this as increasing local
control and Authority um in
previous iterations of similar ideas
were
um were painted as being restricted of
local control so I was wondering if you
could just kind of clarify for people
who made that confusion how this is
actually um a pral control type thing
sure so the the town of Allenstown back
in the 1970s attempted to implement rent
control that was challenged uh when dis
Superior Court Superior Court
transferred the question of whether that
Authority existed under uh New Hampshire
law to the Supreme Court which agreed to
take take that question up it determined
that based under the the then existing
statutory scheme which is the same as it
is now that that Authority did not exist
um if obviously if this were to go into
effect it would um overrule that Supreme
Court decision and Grant that Authority
level further
questions representative
savus thank you Mr chair and thank you
um n i I guess I'm confused nhma
supports the
bill
yes even though there is a Supreme Court
ruling holding that it is not possible
to implement the Supreme Court ruling
was based let me back up a minute
municipalities only have the authority
granted to them under the Constitution
or under uh the the
statutes
the town of Allenstown believed that
they uh that they had the Authority
Under the then existing statutes um to
implement this type of uh local
regulation
the Supreme Court said that's not the
case those that Authority has not been
granted to you by the legislature a bill
like this would Grant municipalities
that
Authority further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony okay that's all I all the pink
cards I have we had uh blue sheet two
people signed in in
favor and with that we will close the
1362 okay before everybody
leaves um so far next week we are
scheduled for Wednesday we haven't
decided if it's going to be exec or
hearings or combination of both
um we will let you know as we get closer
on that that's all I